this show is brought to you by scorebig
next time you go see any gamer show go
to score big first and see how much you
can save the easiest way to save on
tickets download the new the new
scorebig app on your iPhone Enter promo
code Joey at checkout and you'll save an
extra $20 off of your first ticket
purchase you don't have an iPhone that's
fine just go to scorebig.com and use
promo code Joey that's scorebig.com
promo code Joey show is also brought to
you by headspace.com go to headspace.com
and download their free headspace app
and begin the take 10 program for 10
days of guided meditation right now
that's headspace.com joeey and download
the take their free headspace app and
begin the take 10 program right now the
show is also brought to you by on it.com
go to on it.com and use promo code
Church to save 10% on all of the Great
optimization products like ala brain new
mood and strong
bone kick that mule
[Music]
Lee that's as loud as it
goes kick it kick this
[__] I don't care if the Eon
blow I don't give a [__] if your ear
[Music]
sockets
are you [__] kidding me a 400lb black
man singing like that didn't give a [__]
Jack showed up with a
tuxedo a bucket of chicken and you're
getting your [__] little monkey
polished and [__] and then he sings to
you who does that type of
[Music]
[__]
forever and
ever I see you through April 20th you
bad
[__] you're listening to the
Church of What's Happening
Now Lis I at Louis Gomez from patteron
New
Jersey Becky's in the
house and your Uncle
Joey I want to do oh sh
what's the story that dog look at you
you're all smiling you got your Su KN
shirt on sh night shirt I got tacos that
might not have been lizard I'm hoping
you did well now where is this place at
this place is on Burbank cuz you you
keep telling me that the place I went to
had lizards Burbank right up here in
linkers Burbank and linkers cuz you kept
telling me and I'm gullible already that
place oh Jesus Christ now what does this
place have this place has skin this
place has bugs not the one with the
potato tacos like that would be too hard
for you no but the everything else at
the potato taco place is look at 19
potato tacos why are you killing
yourself bouncing everywhere I've never
seen something like this in my I maybe I
potato tacos until I met my Puerto Rican
Italian Brother Louis Gomez listen dog
how the [__] do you live in the east
coast and you go to Taco Bell what
business do you even have in Taco Bell
at this age I'm telling it's because I
am a pothead and you can't go to Taco
Bell there's not very many good tacos in
New York you what about a slice of pizza
I don't even give a [__] who makes it a
black dude anything's got to be better
yeah you even told me yourself you
worked at Taco Bell why would you go
back there and get that meat sometimes
you make mistakes bro no there's no
mistakes like that sometimes listen it's
not like an everyday thing it's like
once a year I [__] up and then I'm like
dude you know what I'm going to get a
[__] Crunch Wrap Supreme I [__] up or
chalupa I [__] up but you work there you
saw behind the curtain yeah that's what
I don't understand you saw behind the
curtain Lou go I'm not talking to some
[__] kid from you
know you know some [__] I'm [__]
you're you're a jersey guy yeah how the
[__] you saw behind the curtain you went
in there and you could tell when you put
the meat in the water that could be a
finger that could be somebody's missing
[__] ant a dog you don't know what
the [__] you eat and listen I like Taco
Bell too I threaten myself to go to Taco
Bell that's how you punish yourself but
I won't go yeah I won't go and listen
nobody likes those sour cream things in
there that burrito supreme after you got
two or three joints in you that shit's
the ma daddy bum the chalupa the chalupa
what's the chalupa that's they take the
gordita [__] then they [__] fry it
they deep fry it it's like that crunchy
chalupa you just can't get that even if
you go to a real taco place in New York
cuz there's a place in East Harlem on6th
and third that has banging tacos it's
like some of the best tacos in New York
City and the stand uh Comedy Club they
have the best fish taco I've ever had in
my entire life period [__] everything
you heard in California go to the Stan
comedy club in grar SE the best fish
taco I've ever had in my entire life
great food period unbelievable they got
great [__] food you go no I've never
been there I've heard that's all I've
heard the [__] food and they put it
down your throat yeah like as soon as
you walk in they hand you a menu and
they're like you got to eat something
you got to eat something and even if you
ate you got to eat and last time I went
I don't know what the [__] it was it was
George it was me and my brother George
went and we just ate something like they
just brought us like sandwiches I'm not
a big sandwich guy when I'm in New York
I know what sandwich I want it was
[__] brilliant yeah like most places
most comedy clubs have like chicken
fingers yeah they got shitty [__]
menus not the stand though well that
that was the thing that was their angle
that was their angle yeah they were like
we're going to have good [__] food
good drinks the environment you're going
to feel like you want to bring get
dressed up like I had oh that's what I
had the AI tuna sandwich yeah yeah like
they don't [__] around with spinach on
it and [__] like aoli sauce like it
was everything there is banging you're
right no when I go to listen I [__]
around when I come here and even here
like I was sitting there yesterday and
Lee was there Lee came by and I was
sitting in the front and all sudden a
Domino's pizza or something like that
came by and my daughter looked at me and
I looked at her and some times I find
weaknesses and I'll buy one of those
pizzas I won't do it man I'm from a
place where pizza was invented I can't
fold but on the road here's the thing
man on the road I've had great pizza on
the road not here I've had great pizza
on the road if I'm on the road I went to
Montreal and I L dominoes because the
pizza in [__] Canada just blows
across the board yeah why would you
think that you're going to get a good
pizza in
Canada cuz I well that you the entire
country of Canada you can't well here's
the problem whether banana used to get
heroin from they're [__] Italian I
forget what their name is and and if you
look at they got a family in fact Eddie
Bravo had a school they had a school
when Eddie told me their name and I go
Eddie that's a Mafia Family there's an
Italian family that sold they imported
the heroin when the heroin comes over
goes to Canada first then it comes into
the United States follow those guies
there's got to be a pizza I went to
Toronto and I know that the Chinese food
was banging I had some burgers that were
bang and I had great food in [__] I
had Cuban food in Toronto Toronto's got
a big Cuban population Toronto's like
the New York New York Canada yeah
there's some good restaurants there but
anywhere else it's going to be hard to
find really good food if you want to you
know you get a a smoked meat sandwich or
poutine they have those specialty shits
in in Montreal but I had I had Chinese
food in Montreal it was [__] awful
yeah well awful I ordered uh what do
they call it um cold sesame noodles they
put peanut butter on SPH you should be
shot and hung you should be shot and
hung you just you couldn't order pork
fried rice and take it from there you
know saying you had to go right for the
gutso Sesame Su noodles which they going
to [__] up anyway because nobody makes
Chinese food like when you were raised
even in patteron there's a great little
Chinese place on a corner that's [__]
delicious and they have what you you're
used to that flavor see when I go to
Buffalo they'll be good Chinese food the
Chinese rice ain't as dark as Jersey but
they still flavor it up they got nice
ribs they got a nice hot and sour soup
you know you got a nice beef on Wick I'm
looking forward to a couple salads to
balance you out a few wings some blue
cheese to get the farts going on the way
back on the plane and at the airport and
buffalo on the way out you get a beef on
Wick sandwich Sunday morning at 6:30 in
the [__] morning they are not making
beef on Wick at 6:30 in the morning yes
they
are they're making tomorrow I fly out a
gate 42 if you don't think I'm thinking
about that hamburger with the [__]
egg on top of it you're [__] out of
your mind my wife would and got me a
roll I'm going to make a nice egg cheese
[__] omelette I'm going to put it on
a sesame seed [__] thing I'm going to
make a little fruit smoothie with almond
milk I'm going to take my blood pressure
medication I'm going to smoke like 30
[__] numbers and I'm eating like
three of these stars and I'm getting on
that [__] plane with the iPod it's
over yeah something changed with
airports they they started having good
food very recently I almost feel like
yes it used to be all just like Cinnabon
and horeshit [__] horid [__] hor
it's a horor show now there's like
pretty good like little [__] places
like nice restaurant you get a steak
Chicago get a banging [__]
Italian meal in Chicago you get a in
Long Island you get a [__] steak like
a doctor you go to [__] C the airport
you're delayed no problem do you ever
bring it on the plane no no no no
there's no need to there's no need to
stink up the [__] plane like a Savage
and [__] like that there's no need to
why are you going to bring your funk
everything smells different on a plane
McDonald's smells delicious when it's
out in the open Bring It On A Plane it
smells like somebody's [__] rooted
ass hole like they tore it out and it's
just hanging there with all the old [__]
dripping that's what McDonald smells
like on a [__] plane so next time
you're going to bring your [__] egg
Big muffin I hope you get cancer don't
bring it on a [__] plane okay eat it
fast like I do inhale that [__] thing
so nobody even sees you what how big is
the ne Bing muffin Street bites yeah
Street bites if you're a [__] Savage
that's how eat McDonald's anyway I'm
always like embarrassed and I'm eating
it so I go in the corner like face away
from everybody on the wall no no in 20
years they're going to throw rocks at
you like when you eat at McDonald's
people going to throw rocks at you like
you were a [__] like 2000 years ago
they rocked you same thing when you eat
McDonald I hope so I hope so I hope so
but they do it all the time people
always bring like sandwiches like what's
I know I know hummus but like what's the
worst thing you've ever seen on a plane
I've seen hummus a man's
foot that's the worst thing I've ever
seen on a plane those [__] animals
with slippers I hope the plane does go
down so they got to run a thousand miles
a better gasoline and no we sneakers and
work boots like I [__] fly okay you
always get your toes covered in case
there's a fly or something they fly with
flip-flops to be [__] cool no I do I
don't bring nothing on a [__] plane I
bring reefer that's it a [__] paper
pen I sit there with the iPod and I look
straight ahead I don't talk to nobody
but don't you get anxiety well you're in
First Class A Lot what [__] anxiety
how do you get anxiety cuz like in the
walk back the one time I did it on the
way to Austin I had to walk all the way
to back at the end of the plane it took
forever for like the food to like I I
didn't like it it was like too much
almost it's not you never get that way
for you what like weed on a plane like
there's something about the altitude or
stone on a plane it makes that flight a
lot easier yeah anything after three
hours you're in hell I'll I'll I'll take
an Amtrak if it's under six hours I'd
rather amtr airplane bad if you live on
the [__] East Coast you could amra
all the way to Fort laudale the MTR is
great but it's it's more expensive than
plane tickets now in some places yeah
well here's the deal with Amtrak if you
call Amtrak yeah it's a cheap thing and
you get there they put you in the back
with a bunch of animals and people
smelling [__] but if you want to go to
the cart then that cost you 12 bucks
that's how they bang oh you want a
pillow oh you didn't tell us you wanted
a pillow that's eight bucks yeah they
bang you through off but then you give
them a flat feet and everything comes
inclusive you have no drum you got free
Wi-Fi you get to walk around the
bathrooms are big Boston to New York is
great it's tremendous if you're trying
to jerk off in an airplane bathroom it's
a [__] nightmare why would you jerk
off an airplane bathroom cuz you [__]
got a long flight I jerk off in almost
every flight I'm ever on no you put the
blanket on and you just move you just
move Different Strokes you know what I'm
saying you don't grip it you just hold
on to with your fingers that's a complet
different move right there how do you do
it on the plane I've always been like
that's disgusting that is really [__]
disgusting what jerking off in the
airplane bathroom [__] yeah I dude I'm I
I am a firm believer in just getting
that out you just got to get it out of
your body yeah but do it before the
plane yeah but what if you're on a long
what makes you want to be on the [__]
plane and jerk why would a human being
what if there's cameras behind those
mirrors there's not that's illegal they
can't do that they this is the FBI they
do what they want they're not okay so
they're going to blow their entire cover
to be like oh we caught you jerking off
why do you think that [__] big mirror
is back no they're watching you that's
okay that kind of turns me on even more
they're watching you somewhere in DC
giggling and they put in your file
that's okay okay and next time you out
of my file I'm completely okay next time
that gets pulled over there's a DOT
where the feds could press and there you
are jerking off in a [__] plane
bathroom and they probably got you on 15
different flights whacking off yeah so
they got you in like a category six like
once they pull you over they're just
going to shoot you CU this guy was
mentally Disturbed he [__] whacked
off on planes we got complaints that's
not one complaint this what's happened
with all these police shootings we don't
know about it but these guys were
jerking off an airplane bathroom all of
them and they can shoot you just shoot
them this guy's a plain jerker offer do
you like watch videos on your phone you
just do it straight from memory well no
cuz they block on the uh Wi-Fi on the
plane you can't look at any porn or
anything they block all those sites so
you have to download pictures or video
beforehand then bring it in the I I go
on my whole computer sometimes text you
I do I do that for hotels when I when CU
I'm always worried about the Wi-Fi at
hotels I'll pre-download it just cuz
otherwise I can't do it from memory
there's no way yeah but that suck I
can't usually I cuz look you're in a
pinch on a plane you can't you can't
stream typically Hotel Wi-Fi at this
point is 2016 I mean you're getting good
Wi-Fi in almost any hotel I also have I
have metrop PCS people make fun of me
because it's like [__] basically
prepaid [__] but I get unlimited uh data
and I get a a Wi-Fi hotspot so I can sit
in a [__] Park and just stream videos
Non-Stop and people make fun of me I pay
$50 a month and these [__] are
spending $120 a month in
data to stream porn in the park I'm not
streaming porn in the park but if I
wanted to I could that's not a bad idea
I don't know I you don't like I I can
you do it from memory or no yeah I can
you know I go through different things
I'll go through different like Motions
like sometimes I've just gotone over
porn and then I'm like all right dude
I'll just go off a memory now I have a I
have a file on my computer I can show
you guys of like 60 different girls that
I've slept with that just P just normal
pictures of them it's almost like just a
so then I can go back to my memories of
the those
chicks what's wrong Joey you don't do
that on the road what's that you don't
you never do that I jerked off in here
the other day you
know where right here in my chair I came
right here I rubbed it in with my foot
and I got left that's it somewhere
there's a kid grown in that carpet right
now like a like a [__] Bubble Guppy
not a bubble guppy those things when you
were kids that you [__] put in water
and they grew seafish whatever the [__]
they were sea monkeys like like a bubble
guppy that's you that's you having a
three-year-old kid right there Lou gobz
it's time for you to do a stop I can't
do half of it half of it you killing
half half half I can't do it you have to
half half you don't listen to me you
don't want these [__] people saying
Lou Gomez you want to the church you
didn't even partake I mean it's bad
enough you go to Taco Bell it's bad
enough you jerk off on planes it's bad
enough you went to Taco Bell after you
work there and you saw behind the
curtain and then it's bad enough you
didn't need a [__] star I remember
one time I was working at KFC when I was
16 and I went for a jerk session oops
that's F don't touch it's in the bubble
guy the Bubble Guppy that's all right
Lee likes Bubble Guppy juice you got
have a half baby half weed star grown
out of your carpet that's what he needs
he lik that [__] we're going 800
milligrams I was uh take a little bite
of the wing I'm here's what I'm going to
do I'm going to [__] take a little
tiny piece that's it so now I feel like
I I did something I you did something
take you to where you need to go
Le it really does taste like [__]
weed Jesus Christ it's delicious and
it's got vitamin C I'm going to be
putting a [__] needle in my dick by
the end of the night no you won't this
is I was I was working at KFC when I was
16 and I wanted to have a jerk sash I
just wanted to like I'm I'm got a crazy
libido like my mom my my mom rented uh
[__] Clockwork Orange when I was like
seven and I remember watching like
multiple gang rape scenes when I was a
kid and I think it like [__] me up
sexually cuz like I I've always had a
very very high libido every I was
masturbated when I was like eight or
nine like really [__] up but I was
working KFC the drive-thru like Prime
Time like 7 o'clock like as busy as it
could possibly be in West AVR New York
and I was like dude I'm getting horny
dude like cuz my dick was rubbing
against the like you know I had
polyester [__] shitty KFC uniform
pants and I was like I got to get it out
of me so I went in the bathroom and I
just lost track of time I got into my
head and that's you had to use it was
Memories Back Then you didn't have
internet or anything this is I'm I'm 34
years old right now so this is you know
[__] nearly 20 years ago and i d i
jerked off I probably spent 20 minutes
just jerking off in there like [__]
edging like making myself almost come
and then stopping myself dude I open up
the bathroom door my manager of my KFC
was this big Mead marine guy dude he was
like what the [__] were you doing I was
like uh taking a [__] he punched me
Square in the face just punched me he
didn't even know I was jerking off he
punched me for taking a [__] for 20
minutes so I'm telling you I got [__]
I have issues so a six- hour plane ride
no Dono
guaranteed one of the biggest points of
contention in my relationship why one of
my my son's mother never got over it we
went to the hospital to have my
son she said oh
no we went to the hospital and before I
knew we were going to be there for like
40 hours you know what I'm saying we had
it uh she wasn't in labor she didn't
like her water didn't break we had it
induced right so as soon as we got there
I was like all right let me go [__]
rubing out really quick because I don't
want to get horny in the middle of all
this and have to [__] be
concentrating on a [__] boner so I I
ended up telling the story on a podcast
and she was [__] livid she never got
over it she NE and she could never
understand how I could possibly go to
the hospital with her to go have our son
and jerk off me neither well some people
get it I'm [__] baffled here that you
even thought about you know cuz that
pussy's beat up I wasn't thinking about
her it looks like somebody threw a
grenade in there and you got It's
[__] amazing I had a friend once that
we went on a vacation this is this had
to be 30 [__] years ago we went on a
vacation and this [__] came into
my room later on with like a folder you
know like when the turys you see with a
manila folder and we were just talking I
went into his room that's what it was I
went into his room to smoke or something
we were probably 22 21 we went to Hawaii
three of
us and I went into this morons
room and this guy had a folder like guys
a [__] folder like it was just and I
asked him what's in there you brought
work with you and he goes no no that's
my
porn and I go what is it and he would
take certain pictures out of Playboy
instead of bringing the whole Playboy he
would just take the sections out and
staple them that's when you're a
professional [__] pervert I don't
know what happened to that guy but I
know for a fact he's got to be in jail
for [__] something or he doesn't
sleep at night who
Staples I had one page out of a magazine
so did I when I was a kid and it was
under my carpet yeah I couldn't even see
her [__] no more it had been rained on
the shower leaked on it it was a [__]
mess and that's I moved on with my life
not only that and you know I don't even
know what the [__] he brought porn with
him on that trip to Hawaii like he was
pissed we couldn't get a VCR or
something like that like I just met you
I knew this guy for like a year they all
had these trips let's go to [__] in
Hawaii I was so [__] embarrassed I
could never imagine traveling with your
[__] stash I mean this this a long
time I get it I completely get
it I mean look what are you going to do
you're on a [__] beach there's no
porn there's no he doesn't know if you
could buy a [__] a porno magazine at
a [__] Lou Gomez do you know I'm nuts
I'm [__] nuts I am [__] nuts and
when I was 21 and doing drugs and I was
even crazier I would go up to women and
say [__] I had I had a friend growing up
stinky this guy was a good-looking dude
he was Italian American Indian so every
time he got hammered he went off
character he was a gentleman in the
daytime but he would go up to Becky
after four drinks Becky would known for
four years he go up to Becky and go
who's next Becky let me give that monkey
a shot and he was so goodlooking that it
worked 60% of the time you had three
drinks in you what the [__] you know so
I learned from him I would say [__] Fu
all that nice guy [__] when you go to
these clubs you got to just tell these
Savages listen I got a grandma [__]
blow I got three quots you here talking
to this jerk off about [__] insurance
let's go up to the room let's eat your
[__] let's put a quo in that
[__] and put you to work and I
just turn my back and walk away and six
out of 10 they walk back to the room
with me and four times they just sit
there like what the [__] did you just
say to me but I didn't give a [__]
doesn't matter it's it's about doesn't
really matter it's about going up to
them and going listen it's 2:00 talking
to this jerk off look at him look at him
you got you what's he going to do to you
I got an you just show her the rock you
give her a taste then just show it I
tried like I obviously not saying I had
Coke but like I always I imagin okay you
got to be like mean can't be nice and
after like two sentences it just doesn't
work not mean but affirmative confident
in those days the cocaine and look at me
I'm a [__] bum I didn't give a [__]
when I would do that Coconut Grove
improv I would say than to women down
there cuz everybody snorting [__] in
Miami everybody goes to Coconut Gro to
snort and [__] nobody goes to there to
see Disney characters in 99 people went
to [__] Coconut Grove to party and
that's the way it was since the early
80s Coconut Grove now it's changed and
they have a couple clubs and the karaoke
plays so did like if you just saw a girl
in a bar right would you assume would
you just open up with the coke line
assuming she did Coke no let's say with
talking she ends up in the circle she's
a good-looking girl
whatever 3 four at the store you got to
ask them that was the scariest I would
never do it in a group the only time I
ever did it is if like they left the
group oh yeah if they left the group
then you got to S and if they're doing
you blow it's even easier you just tell
them what's the story well then they owe
you yeah what do you want to do you want
to S here let's go back to the hotel I
got [__] two eight balls you got no
work tomorrow well but about my car
leave the [__] car there it's over
and that's it I'll six out of 10 times
I'll tie you up just tell them what you
got in planned [__] I'll stick a finger
up your ass I'll tie you up and they'll
just look at you dog like what the [__]
did you just saying what do you give a
[__] yeah I learned that a long time ago
tomorrow morning you're going to wake up
and it's not going to really matter
nobody's going to matter everybody's
[__] up everybody goes out for the
certain reason nobody goes out to go
home
alone yeah so you know then why are guys
so scared when they're young or may
maybe I maybe I'm everybody's [__]
scared when they young because we buy
into TV shows we buy into grease that
you got to sing you know what I'm saying
you got to sing to a [__] and [__] uh
it's the same thing listen
dog I was friends with this girl that
was the most aggressive woman I had ever
seen in my life I never saw nothing like
that I never slept with her or nothing
but I hung out with her and she was very
aggressive towards guys I mean to the
point where she would make guys melt do
you know what I'm saying like she would
just knock them off that game she would
say what I was saying to women to guys
and guys can't handle that that [__] me
up if a girl if a girl's too sex dude I
that she would go off on guys if a girl
like I hate condoms but if a girl is
aggressively being like Oh take your
condom off that just [__] me up I'm
like I can't I can't even I need to be
the creep I need to be the uh I need to
be the one who's hunting if I'm the one
who's being hunted it just kind of [__]
my game up but that it's all he's right
dude it's all numbers like if you
literally go up to a girl in a bar 100
girls and go hey let me just [__] you in
the bathroom right now there's a ratio
it's predetermined by the universe if
you ask every woman in the world there's
a number one out of however many women
are going to say yes and if you
understand that then you that's where
all your confidence comes from it's in
sales they say every no gets you closer
to a yes that's the theory right there
you go all right say no [__] the next
one might say yes I once pulled a girl
out of her house with her
boyfriend set the stage and took her to
the hotel down to the corner I went to
school with her name was Lori Jack all
right they called her Lor Jack cuz she
didn't she was
from she was from Wayne New Jersey and
transferred to most of my family's from
okay and she transferred to northb and
her s Mo and started [__] but she had
a dry [__] so they called The Fair View
the dry hump I mean these guys are
torture Fair View is a city above North
Bergen so she didn't come or she her
[__] didn't get wet so they called The
Fair View the dry hump that's such a
weird thing to make some like make fun
of someone about these [__] are
crazy okay I didn't like it I never
really dug it she always creeped me out
a little bit but at the end of the day
the bitch's face was [__] up like not
she's still pretty on Facebook she's on
Facebook in fact I shocked her about
three months ago right so she uh had but
the body was on fire at that age and I
hadn't seen her from high school and one
night I go to corkies and I'm [__] up
I got a [__] half a Coke in my pocket
I've been up for two days and who walks
in but this chick with a [__] minis
skirt on and then she starts talking to
me like from high school I knew her
boyfriend in high school starts talking
to me I give her a few bumps and the
[__]
disappears and I go this dirty [__] she
was looking like she hypnotized me with
that little minis skirt on so she told
me where she lived she lived with this
guy named Lou denado when I was a kid
lonado thought he was a big shot and he
opened up a massage par and he he wanted
to hire me Danny
Bano Jimmy Val like a bunch of us to be
bodyguards at the thing and he wouldn't
pay us cash he wanted us for the chicks
to blow us and I had never gotten a
[__] at that time so I went in there
I was like one of the dog guys there one
night one of the girls like so when do
you want your [__] I want you to come
in my hair listen to me I ran home and
almost cried come in your hair what are
you talking I'm not going to waste my C
in your hair who comes in the hair I had
never heard that before I ran the [__]
out of there but anyway lonado was a
pervert he said he had a connection with
the Yankees I was there snorting coke
one night two nights I like Lou he was
kind of crazy he was one of those int
that just
talked so she tells me she said Louis
Donal says 3:00 comes guys I'm [__]
honed up I got made maybe 40 bucks in my
pocket but I got a half ounce of the
best Coke in the [__] world and a
couple joints and a pocket full of pills
I got nowhere to go I say [__] it I'mma
knock on Louis Don's door do you know I
locked knocked on Louis Don's door this
[__] answered it with a robe
like like a Playboy and he goes what can
I do for you I goes do can I talk to
Lori for a second something went down at
the [__] B that I got to ask her some
questions and she came down with a Rob
on I'm like you got to come with me I
want to [__] you I just broke it down in
a minute she's like I can't Lou I don't
give a [__] about Lou let's go and Lou
went downstairs and let us talk so I go
get your purse let's go and we just
[__] tore ass out of there and we
went to the tip top Hotel on tley Avenue
and we walk in we had a [__] few
cocktails and [__] so I'm like so what's
the story you going to take those
panties off and I never forgets he goes
you gotta guess what color they
are and I go red and she goes they're
orange close
enough
and that was all I remember like we just
started snowing blow and [__] and
sucking that's all I remember now this
is Friday night from 4: to maybe 7 in
the morning and the next thing I know I
wake up and Doug fluty is throwing that
[__] bomb they're replaying it he had
just thrown the bomb and they were about
to interview him and I remember waking
up she was still naked laid there I
washed in washed my [__] brushed my
teeth whatever the [__] I had and I just
left of that and I never saw her again
till 3 months ago on Facebook and she
friended me and I said to her do you
remember what happened the last time I
told I saw you and she's like what I go
you remember you don't remember I robbed
Louis denado cuz Louis dado left it his
posit bag on top of the refrigerator so
I took that to go on the way out too you
know me do I was [__] nuts D
nuts you stole his chick and then took
the money on the way out took the money
on the way up to pay for the hotel room
unbelievable guys I should be ashamed
how old were you were you in high school
no I was uh way too old to be doing that
21 that's not bad I just turned 21 we
used to do that all the time we used to
bring chicks over the apartment me and
Dave Smith and then when they go to the
bathroom we go through their purse and
just [__] take money out of their
purse like scumbags just pieces of
garbage I I used to do magic tricks when
I was like a little kid like uh like 14
13 years old and we we this was our game
cuz I I got pretty good light of hand so
we would play strip poker with chicks
like teenage girls we just play strip
poker and I'm just [__] ping Kings
and Aces the whole time just getting
girls naked like we're just sitting
there with our clothes completely on
we're [__] like all right dude I mean
we were [__] just grimy [__] one
night I was all [__] up I had just
been in La two three years it's a Monday
night and I go to the Laugh Factory and
I got a little bit of coke I got like a
half a 20 and I had cut in it I'm like
this [__] Coke this [__] Coke is
terrible and I go to the Laugh Factory
I'm sitting behind there and Paul
rodrigus is on stage and some [__]
hot chick is hackling him I mean
hackling him and he gets a thrown out
and as she walks past me I go this is my
Victim for the night and she's out there
yelling and screaming on Sunset and I go
out there and I'm like what's the
problem and she starts talking to
me and
this [__] looks at me she goes there a
bar around here it was a Monday night
she goes there a bar around here I'm
like there's tons of [__] bars around
here she goes I just need a bottle of
beer or a liquor store I go uh let's go
there one over here I didn't even
[__] know where the hell we we walked
like a block we couldn't find it all I
know is this chick went in her pocket
and took out a wad that would kill a
[__] horse at this time I was living
on Gavin's couch just getting $15 spots
and i' made a decision right there that
I was mug in this
chick like right there and there I knew
that money was
mine I had a car with no insurance no
registration the brakes were going we
start talking I give her a bump to
soften her up I get her in the car I
take it I take it down to soften her up
sure to soften her up you got to give
him something I take her down to [__]
uh the liquor store like the shitty
neighbor to Hollywood we got like a
bottle of vodka we're drinking vodan
Gatorade in the [__] car and then she
tells me her story that she lives in
Seattle and she's down here for a
convention and but this chick is too hot
for this story and she's too you know
what I'm saying she's too Hy and she's
bad the [__] is
bad and all of a sudden she's down here
for a convention and she's engaged and
you
know and I'm sitting there taking the
[__] I know where this is going by
this time I'm a professional you can't
get one by me right this
is this I'm 36 you're not getting it's
over I got got you you're in my lirer
it's over I don't even want to [__] you
I just want to [__] take your money
so she's telling me that this convention
took her down in my layer you're in my L
it's over you taking uh she came down
here to go to a a seminar her job sent
her to be a seminar to do some [__] in
an office and they kept it downtown at a
Japanese Hotel like a badass hotel
that's where the whole staff was so she
goes if you take me down there I have
tequila and more alcohol I go why are we
driving around in a car with no brakes
no insurance no registration drinking
when you got a [__] hotel room so we
get down to the hotel room now the whole
time it's 11:30 and my coke dealer
closes at 1 so if I'm going to mug this
[__] I got to get to it I got to step
this up we have drinks we toast you know
she's like [__] it you know this is on
the company you know and all a sudden
she starts telling me how she stripped
for four years so I knew finally the
clouds part to show you the color of the
sky you know what I'm saying so I'm
sucking all this in and I'm looking at
that pocket it's sticker than a
[__] and I give it two more
bumps and show me your T come on she I
can't I'm engaged she takes her tit out
so we're on once they once they say
they're engaged and they drop the tit on
you it's all good you got a commitment
you know what I'm saying we're working
with
something I can take this to the next
level we got something I just back off a
little bit give her air let the tequila
to get to it and then we'll take this to
the next level I rip out the rest of the
coke we're banging the [__] Coke out
of lines not her other tits falling out
I grab them can I smell them yeah I'm
sucking the whole [__] thing tits
don't have a smell I don't give a [__]
right next thing you
know next thing you know feeling her
monkey I [__] open up I can't I'm
engaged okay I'm sorry don't worry you
know I'm respectful I'm a Catholic no
don't worry about eight minutes later
I'm back on like a
barracuda I got
sh this time I got a shoe on off good I
got the one shoe off you went for the
shoe because I got to take the pants off
I'm not going to eat a [__] half with
lit you know what I'm saying like a
[__] three-year-old I got to whip
those pants off and [__] so I take the
shoe off she starts to cry again she she
puts the but this time she don't put the
shoe back on so I know I got my hooks in
her I know I got this dirty [__] she's
walking around with the apartment with
one shoe talking to me how she can't
cheat on him she's never cheated on him
she loves him you know she buried his
mother just a bunch of [__] and the more
[__] she's telling me another shot of
tequila too I'm softening her up I got
her like in the fourth round now it's a
seven round fight right but it's 10
after 12 I better get to it I better get
to it we start swamping spit her pants
come off I take the other shoe off I
start fingering her she's talking she's
half crying I can take your hand out
just look at it whatever fine next thing
you know I get my [__] head between
man it smells like a gyro but I don't
give a [__] cuz I'm trying to get her
pants off but she left the shoe on the
left pant so I can't get that [__]
that scoop so I had to make up a story
why to take her shoes off so I had like
say something to her and then just take
the shoe off and take her pants off and
eat her [__] I didn't give a [__] and
now I'm eating her and I'm fingering her
but I'm on the floor with this octopus
hand trying to get those
jeans you can't even be passionate like
this anymore they call it rape today DG
I'm fing going to eat her [__] her
clits and lods all the whiff is coming
out you know when everything starts
coming out when you yeah and the next
thing you know I hit the Jerica I hit
the money I take the top out and it's a
single I'm pissed I got to eat that
monkey I'm taking and I'm ripping out
singles what happened to the hundreds
she had finally hit the hundreds and I
take like two out and I leave it on the
floor and I take another one out boom
and that's good enough for me I've
already eaten this [__] she's about to
come I already came just from looking at
her naked I'm done I'm over there
breathing heavy she said I can't believe
you let me eat my [__] my all don't
worry about nothing I'm fingering her
[__] she's going back down I put the
money in my pocket and about a minute
later I [__] get up and I go oh my
God I didn't put quarters in the meter
I'm going to get
Toad and she goes all right hurry up
come back I [__] left that was it
that's my [__] I didn't muggle
completely are you guys friends on
Facebook no she disappeared that's
actually not that's a pretty good guy
just to not r completely you could have
taken all the money I just wanted to get
high and I made it on the 101 from
downtown I made it to Dante by 1:00
that's all that matters you understand I
beat the deadline sometimes you got to
beat the clock dog you know what I'm
saying yeah man this is the time but
this
is listen man that was half the [__]
fun when you're growing up and you're
doing drugs yeah well The Thrill the
just the thrill of even doing that like
just to see if you can we used to we
used to steal
like crazy we used to go to the mall and
it wasn't it was for the money half the
time but it was like just a thrill of I
mean I the the guy the guy who own
collabria pizza would send us to the
mall and he would just give us shoe
sizes and he'd be like all right go pick
up sneakers he was like I need you know
three Nikes two rebok he would just give
us sizes it didn't have to be a specific
style and he'd give us $20 per pair of
shoes that we would steal and I would
just I had a buddy who worked there who
gave me the key that you could just take
the uh the things off model and I'd walk
in with shopping bags and just walk out
with like 10 pair of sneakers in each
bag and just walk the [__] out of the
mall I used to do it with um golf clubs
too he he would pay us like 20 bucks per
Golf Club cuz Golf Club I never played
golf but apparently they're pretty
expensive thank God yeah Taco Bell
patteron and golf I shoot myself with a
[__] head thank God there's one
bright [__] but I put one Golf Club
down each leg and walk out like I had
broken legs and we would do that almost
two or three times a week week we used
to uh we used to rob the wishing well at
the Rainforest Cafe at like 2:00 in the
morning we go in and we would just
[__] cuz they keep the mall doors
open at the palate Center Mall when I
was like 17 18 years old and me and my
buddy Toby Smith I mean this is how we
made weed money like for probably two
years I mean we would do this the
[__] security they would chase us
like [__] you because they can't touch
you they're not allowed to grab you in
New York I don't know it is in Cali but
security guards can't put their hands on
you they can like try to detain you and
call theop STS but they can't if you're
stealing [__] you better get the [__]
out of my face what are you going to do
can't put your hands on me that's it so
we used to [__] take like $100 and
change every like Tuesday and Thursday
night and just go to the Coin Star
machine and just [__] dump a bunch of
wet coins into the Coin Star machine
that was it but it was like it was fun
and it was like a fun weird thrill I
don't think I paid for toothpaste until
I was
30 I mean I would literally just take
toothpaste from [__] Dwayne Reed and
just just I'd be shopping and I just
[__] drop it in my pocket
because it didn't make sense to me to
spend $7 on toothpaste you
know but listen from
78 to 2003 I robbed everything I could
yeah I just robbed sometimes for the
[__] sake of it sometimes to prove a
point I robbed everything I
could what's the biggest thing you ever
stole I robbed a jewelry store like
stuck them up no weapon went in there
took the [__] shelves and ran out
there wow before they had and this is on
Bergen Line Avenue in Jersey which all
those jewelry stores had
buzzers I love stealing I love stealing
there was something about it when I was
a kid that I didn't like for the
Catholicism raising but once I did it
like in the seventh grade I was gone
yeah I was gone with it because
everybody around me was stealing and
they were talking about it so it felt
like it had been accepted it was almost
like uh I don't remember who said
somebody said it but it's like uh it was
in a movie the kid's father said it to
him and he was like that's it if you can
steal you won you know if you didn't get
caught like that's almost like your work
that's how you got paid and I kind of
like weirdly get it even almost on like
a moral level it's like it's your job to
keep your [__] you know what I'm saying
and if you're not if you don't have your
eyes I people don't steal from me
because I'm very paranoid about people
taking my [__] I never like leave my
door open or you know I don't have a car
anymore but I would I would always make
sure that it was locked but if somebody
like got me I would feel like I wouldn't
feel like I needed to call the cops like
I [__] up because I didn't keep my
eyes on my [__] you
know well it's it's really weird how
when I'm walking around that's what I'm
looking for always is security flaws
like it's just a natural instinct of
mine that I'm always looking for
security flaws I see with my eyes a lot
of other people don't see because I'm a
criminal it's something you can't shake
it's in you you know what I'm saying so
I see people body movement you know you
know people's body movement cuz that's
the body movement you had I know in
somebody's up to no good just by their
body movement I know the movements you
know last night we had a weird situation
those skateboarders oh yeah I thought I
was going to have to run one of those
[__] over what it cost see I'm
at an age right now dog well I'll run
you with the [__] car yeah like I
don't have time to fist fight you I'm
not a Commando I'm not a hand-to hand
coming back guy that ship sailed I see
you at Night by a 7-Eleven and you
torment me I will [__] hit you with
that [__] car and drag you and then
back it up and run over your [__]
head and I'll make up some [__] story
you understand me I'm not take those
kids last night they were scary yeah
yeah there were there were 10 of them
you got to hit four of them yeah got to
hit four of those [__] with a
car at least you got to hit one of them
hard enough to the other ones go all
right all this [__] is not
[__] around you know they didn't know
that it's weird the things I saw at that
age at that age we would [__] with a guy
and he would light us up on Bergen line
ad him I remember again getting lit up
at like 13 by like a 17 18 year older
cuz we thought we were cute like punched
in the [__] mouth bleeding lit up
like you're walking with your buddy and
he got beat up and your other buddy
who's a black belt in karate he got
[__] beat up too everybody got beat
up because the fear was just the way
this guy [__] beat us up you know
these kids don't know that they didn't
know that what were they doing last
night they were just in the middle of
the street 11 fucking3 at night with
skateboards they made a ramp by [__]
7-Eleven so they weren't even that bad
of kids I thought they were trying to
rob you guys you were just annoyed with
them they were trying to be weird they
weren't doing anything like they weren't
doing violent they they were being
they're being per like uh what is it
like uh they're being obnoxious on
purpose they were just like taking as
long as they could to walk behind a car
that's trying to back out nothing really
that aggressive but it's just like
they're going to laugh about it later
tell you could tell you could tell I
ain't a Swami from salami you follow me
but you could tell that these
[__] don't know right and the
beauty of it was a lead point to that
we're a block from a cop station 30
[__] yards that went down from a c le
30 [__] even like cuz you even said
at the end a podcast or two ago that
that would be a good one to Rob and I
couldn't believe it cuz it's literally
right next to a police station yeah and
and closer is to police station the
better it is to R cuz they can't even
figure it out this their circuit short
circuit you just hit them right in their
[__] neighborhood takes them 3
minutes more to [__] react to you 3
minutes [__] more but I I love you
know when I first moved to North Bergen
these kids would go to Sea caucus and
Rob punks to light on fire and they sell
them door to door who knocks on your
door these kids did [__] that you know
like it was just crazy but then we
started robbing motorcycles you know
when I was in Colorado and I got out of
the halfway house I had a friend that
used to send me stolen [__] let me tell
you how different the societies
are in Colorado in California right now
dog I'll give you a I'll give you a
truck right now put it right out here
right now filled with [__] speakers
and tell you get me whatever you can for
them I guarantee you'll sell three
[__] speakers cuz that's not accepted
in the California Society that's not
accepted outside of Staten Island Jersey
those the people who like pull up to you
and say hey man I found no no no no no
no those are the people that you go to a
bar in Patterson and on payday they show
up yo yo yo yo can I get your
[__] attention please and [__]
look at these [__]
shoes that's it Italian [__] shoes
300 a pair you're going to get them for
[__] $85 like that guy in barber shop
that's an actual thing that happens yes
yes he just said it he go shoplifting
let's say he comes back to capoo and
capoo don't have capuzzo is not there
this [__] is look yeah go to
havest go to havra and we'd open the
back of the trunk I do that's what we
used to do this what you do and the kids
would come up and be like all right I'll
try to sell them for 25 now and get even
more money and get you follow me you're
always hustling you don't get stuck with
nothing yeah I didn't need a [__]
size rebok no stolen anything you steal
I'm making a profit even if you give me
$3 yeah like I always learn how to exist
in every Market I lived when it was in
Boulder I went right to the record
stores and I would Rob CDs and bring
them up the corner and [__] sell them
for $7 a piece I would it was like a car
I lose $5 in a [__] half a mile walk
but you know there was always a way to
make a [__] stupid living somebody
asked on Twitter what's the number of
the episode where Diaz talked about
bringing return s back to Sears and all
that [__] when I first started comedy
from N I got divorced from ' 92 to '95
guys I lived off returns oh yeah I would
walk into a store and not even walk out
of the store I would take the stuff and
walk right up to customer service and go
hi you could do that today but today we
got cameras yeah but you can't go back
to the same place but I did when I was
19 that's exactly how I made all of my
money when I F I was going to Baro
College in New York City and what I
figured out was the return on books from
the book bookstores for the colleges
they were crazy so I'd go into the I'd
go into the bookstore right and in the
beginning of the year everyone's
bringing their books from the previous
year and returning them and you get like
you know maybe 20% of what you paid for
the previous year I take it right in the
middle of the store I drop on the floor
I jump on the books a little bit to beat
them up a little bit and I bring them
straight back to the return counter and
I would do that all the time to make
money I learned when I was probably
eight I just I'd go and I found a
receipt on the ground and I just the
idea came to me it was very natural I
had no money we went to buy candy or
whatever it was and I got a receipt I
was like oh I could just go get chicken
and it says I bought chicken you know
and bring this over and I just returned
it it was as simple as that easy way to
make money super easy way to make money
I dude I used to that that was I was a
[__] scam artist a straight up scam
artist up until I was about 19 I moved
to New York City and I started promoting
for comedy clubs on the streets of New
York City I was one of the original guys
if you walk through Time Square I like
hey you want to go see a comedy show
that was my [__] I was one of the first
guys that were doing that out there I
worked for the first company that ever
did that uh called new genis Marketing
Solutions but that same guy who punched
me in the face the KFC guy I almost
robbed that a different KFC he started
working at another KFC and I hadn't
worked at KFC in like two or three years
but I knew at the end of the night they
had about a $3,500 drop from like the
day of sales in cash that they would
bring they put in a little blue bag lock
it you know one of those like leather
lock bags and he'd go to his car drive
to the bank do a deposit boom so dude I
remember man my buddy Vinnie fante drove
me there I had a [__] ski mask right
and a [__] black hoodie I and I stole
the ski masking hoodie from Bradley's
because I didn't want I didn't want
anybody to know that I bought it I
wanted to [__] dude I created no
paper trail and I had a screwdriver and
I was going to put it like like one of
those old timing movies like yeah stick
him up I was going to do that [__] and I
chickened out at the last minute I'm
really glad I did man because this guy
first of all this guy would have [__]
me up he was like an OM Marine was
[__] Jack diesel he there's no way he
was going to believe me I have this
shitty voice so he was going to
immediately recognize my voice and I was
hiding behind the bushes he came out he
walked right by I was shaking I was
[__] just Shak Shing and he walked
right into his car and I and I just let
him go and I didn't Rob him and I ended
up moving to New York City to go to Baro
College a few weeks later and I got that
job selling Comedy Club tickets and I
started making like $500 a week selling
Comedy Club tickets and that was it that
was enough for me that I was like all
right well I don't need to [__] rob a
KFC you know being 19 making $500 a week
you know even even now I think for a
19-year-old kid that's pretty decent um
but in a weird way comedy almost saved
my life because I didn't I didn't know
what I never been to a comedy club in my
life not once in I never thought about
standup comedy except for like Death Jam
I used to watch when I was a kid like
Eddie Murphy but that you know making a
little bit of dough cuz I was [__] I
was poor poor like I was welfare my mom
stopped buying me Christmas gifts when I
was like 11 I was buying my own school
clothes like I I I've worked every day
since I was about 11 years old I've
always had a job I've always had a way
to make money um and it was always very
important to me cuz I watched my mom be
on welfare and have food stamps and I
was always very embarrassed and very
ashamed of the fact and I remember when
I was really young I when maybe seven or
eight having the thought like what are
you doing get a [__] job like why are
you sitting there smoking cigarettes
you're not doing anything to make money
you're just collecting a paycheck off of
other people that are paying their taxes
at a really really young age I remember
connecting with that thought so it drove
me crazy
too like I don't like nothing listen you
got to if you're going to be a crook be
a crook at least you're doing something
you're getting a check from somebody
once a month under your [__] you know
I never forget getting insulted they
like now that you went to prison you
could claim di disability disability and
get a check every month like so every
month I'm just going to sell my S for
1,200 bucks that's it so I don't have to
have a job I can make more [__] 1,200
bucks at that time I'm like I can make
four 5,000 in a [__] month just
walking around being me yeah I had done
it for years just being me walking
around 4 5,000
I I don't know how I did it every month
but I put it together for years yeah you
have some bad months but when you're
living on [__] like I would get
dressed up in Fort Le in '
85 I've been listening to this album
lately R the second album they put out
not the first one the second one they
put out rat r at yeah rat with
uh Percy and the other [__] dudes and
I had this cassette play and in '
85 I think of those times at night
sometimes when I'm by myself I'm coming
down I haven't even started to write
about those
times that's how close I was to going to
prison for [__] life because a job
was not even on my Horizon from February
of 85 to July 1st of 85 I pretty much
left the house every morning at 9:00 and
whatever happened happened so that 4 or
5,000 never came from like a job at all
no I had sometimes I'd get a a job for a
week here but it's $10 an hour to be a
laborer you can quantify that cuz you
were spending it on drugs right is that
why you know that was that much I was
quantifying it because I was living
without an apartment I would be in a
hotel for a month okay I was eating
three meals out and I'm not talking guys
I didn't eat no my life the worst thing
I did was a lunch special from a Chinese
restaurant $695 with you know what I'm
saying you pick that [__] sichan they
give you an egg roll they give you a
bowl of soup they give you the noodles
they give you the white rice they give
you a [__] cold sesame noodles no I
don't do no [__] cold sesame noodles
but they take care of you in those
things but I was always eating out and I
was the type of guy I go for a $20
breakfast I always you know what I'm
saying so it wasn't even the drug
addiction which you have to add into it
was the 100 a night for a hotel in Fort
Lee you know or I would live in those
[__] hotels for a week they Char
Manhattan 275 a week you pay 275 a
[__] week guys I was 21 I just told
you the story when I [__] went I
couldn't pay the room I got thrown out I
went down a Friday night and I get to
the front with the money in my pocket I
made like $200 that day and it was I
owed him like 160 for the week and I get
to the window and the guy's like we we
have your stuff your stuff isn't I
couldn't get to talk to the lady so I
went outside of the Hotel this is in
Fort Lee and I went to my room and I put
the key in and somebody was in the
shower a couple were in the shower
[__] and I open the door and there's
her purse and there's a [__] uh a
[__] envelope from the bank in the
old days that the cash came out of the I
clipped that I they really made it nice
and easy to find somebody's money oh my
God I went to the front I told the
Indian to give me my bag okay okay I'll
leave I leave you go I [__] hail I
got a cab and you know what I did when I
lived in that hotel let me tell you how
[__] crazy I went on a t cuz the most
fun I had was doing this [__] I would
[__] live in that hotel you know what
I'm talking about right off rof four
when you come over the [__] Bridge
all those hotels in Jersey that you hit
there I know I did I robbed all those
hotels not the hotels I would stay at
those hotels yeah but you know all those
gas stations yeah when you first hit
there's like six gas stations what
happened I mean I know well cuz I take
the bus over there my sister picks me up
when I go home now so yeah so one day
I'm walking like an [__] in like
March of 85 I'm walking like an [__]
and I go to the city and and I get a bag
of reef on 171st Street and I walk back
over to Lincoln to the bridge and I walk
and I see uh
what the [__] I lost my train of thought
there gas station I see this gas station
I walk I'm I'm on roof four cars are
doing 90 pass me coming off the [__]
bridge and I'm walking and all a I see a
Sonoco and whatever and the first one I
go in there to get some water or
something it says help wanted I'm like
what are you looking for here goes the
guy goes midnight
shift so I said let me do the paperwork
so my buddy you know the you know now
you know the gas station by Lincoln
Tunnel H right right there we Hawking
right there it's the last [__] gas
station as you're making the the [__]
right right to the Lincoln Tunnel to go
back into [__] the city right there
there a gas station right there I know
exactly what my Budd was a fck it's
always crazy traffic right always crazy
traffic my buddy put himself through
[__]
MIT working there you ready for this
hanging pumps another forgotten [__]
another thing that those computers did
for you I I love my iPhone yeah that's
why now nobody can steal in the old days
the [__] gas went tick tick take you
saw the gas move so when it rains in
Jersey what do they do they pump your
gas well two states today now they have
to anyway it's all full service Jersey
and [__] port and Oregon they have to
pump your gas you don't pump the gas so
my buddy lubs would get up the [__]
yellow thing and he'd be out there in
the rain and the gas station would be
crazy he'd be a sophomore in high school
and he figured out that when [__]
some guy comes in and gets $3 worth of
gas that's your $3 he would would pump
that $3 in that and then when Becky
comes in and she goes I want 10 he would
pump that same thing in there so he took
$3 from you right off the top you're not
going to get out and argue with him it's
[__] raining now he did this all
night he put himself through MIT you do
know that right four nights a week he
was probably robing them for two G's a
[__] night hanging pumps that's an
all forgotten art they can't even do
that no more you get killed doing that
[__] and he I knew that he knew the
manager so I would tell him to give me
the names of the people who got fired
for stealing who the [__] do you people
think you're dealing with here so once
he clipped me the names I went back to
the gas station I said you know what I
thought about I want the job and I gave
one of the names they fired for
stealing and you're put another you're
going to put another thing on his record
now who gives a [__] you know what I'm
saying once a thief always a thief it's
a jungle out there you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm talking about
what do I give a [__] I just needed an
ID guy said you they didn't didn't even
check my ID guys that's how smooth I was
just come come back tonight at midnight
and make him laugh a little bit I train
you you train me
[__] and the first night I
realized I thought I was going to sit on
my ass all night it was busy I hadn't
had money in weeks and all I'm pack in
my [__] Pockets at 20s and 10 my guy
said to me every time you got $1,000
drop it well I held on to like $3,000 it
was 4 in the [__] morning guess what
I
did I [__] locked that door I put out
of business and I walked on
$3,000 okay and I took the [__] he
had a bank with all the singles like the
backup chains I got him for another
grand I left the gas station open for
hours I just walked away went home and I
go I got a new career so I just went to
from gas station the gas station you
look at and they were all looking for
midnight to
he who wants to cover that shift some if
a guy comes in with a missing eye you
got to give him a shot what do you give
a [__] you know that takes you you
you're the owner you got to do this [__]
[__] I did it 10 times bro yeah and then
I would call you up and I wouldn't say
nothing to you what are you doing no I'm
my home come over to you know the gas
station come over to the gas station and
you I see you pull up and I go go down
and like just walk right to you and we
take off yeah and I can I almost got
caught one time at the Lombardi gas
station in the sea caucus that's where I
came real close the cops were looking
for me and everything but again it was
raining and thunder and lightning and it
was all these buses headed to New York
it's a parking ride so they said [__] it
we're not going to go through who gives
a [__] let him go so I never forget I
got off on 42nd street and I and I
bought the Bruce Lee suit from Game of
deck and [__] you know what I'm
saying so what did the owner call the
cops on you or something bro who knows I
just walked away yeah that was it do you
still get the let me ask you this
because this is what I I said this
recently on my other podcast and my my
friends were giving me [__] but to this
day like I won't steal I mean I got a
kid now I'm trying to like teach him
actual real values and you know I'm not
trying to be a piece of [__] I'm trying
to raise a good kid but if I see like a
water of cash like on a table my
instinct like just I look at it I'm like
I want to take that [__] money every
[__] day it's like it's like an
addiction it's like I wanna I want to
take that [__] money if you're that
stupid that was always my [__]
metaphor when I went out so I wouldn't
feel guilty if you're that stupid I got
to rob you yeah okay and you said
something very stuff before the easiest
people I robbed like I don't want people
to think I used to Rob mothers at their
homes I [__] up a few things you know
I'm not going to lie to nobody but my
main thing was drug dealers I loved them
and I loved when I saw holes cuz you
can't be that [__] stupid yeah I saw
really good drug dealers and then I saw
guys that I'd sit there and
go this is going to be like [__]
nothing I had a you probably ran the
scam before because it's it's an old
time I didn't even know about it but I
had a buddy of mine who did it and uh I
called my weed dealer it wasn't even a
buddy mine this guy I met like twice
selling Comedy Club tickets on the
street together we were like selling
tickets and I was like oh I I can get
weed I'll call my buddy so I called this
Kid From Brooklyn he was like he the kid
asked me that I was working with he's
like how old do you know him I was like
oh you know I just started buying weed
from him a couple weeks ago he was like
all right so the kid came up and this
guy was a little bit older than I was
like 19 20 at the time this guy was like
maybe 30 you know what I'm saying but he
looked like a man you know to to young
kids 17-year-old white kid comes up to
sell me weed I'm buying weed he comes up
he just flips open his wallet and goes
please get up against the wall get up
against wall right now and the kid dude
he's like [__] his pants almost and he
was like a [__] dude he starts running
his pockets pretending to be the cops
and taking his weed and I started
laughing because I thought he was just
[__] around I didn't realize that it
was a scam I was like oh he's just
[__] around I know this guy and this
kid looked at me he was like are you
[__] idiot and then it all fell apart
and the kid was like what the [__] that
K never answer my phone call again but
it would have worked like he was like
dude I do this all the time he was like
you get some [__] young teenage kid
you're buying weed from just Rob him I
was like they're not going to you're the
cops to them that's it you let them off
with a
warning that's it it's I know a lot of
people I never pulled that one that's I
had a badge for years and I got myself
out of binds with that badge in certain
situations I just what was your name
don't
matter Dick Tracy does it [__] matter
whatever I even took a a business card
and cut the head up and put it in there
where the cops thing
was in fact that's buried somewhere I
buried that that's where the [__] that
badge is I never did nothing with it I
had it for like three years that's a
solid scam just Rob young kids for their
drugs
easy it's way easier than getting a job
at a gas
station Hey listen anytime you involve
guns and I always tell people that in
the 80s especially in the 80s a lot of
people got involved in drugs that didn't
know didn't know the extent of it didn't
know that at 4 in the morning people
lose their minds
and you have cocaine in the house they
saw it when they went over there yeah
now they're going to come over there
with a story or to mention or they going
to go over there and take it from me
that's why I didn't like that drug at
all because people you always left the
door open if people knew where your
house was I know you got it we could
come over there we're going to torment
you to you [__] give it to us so I
don't know I always felt weird like
robbing somebody like that I didn't
start robbing I would Rob drug dealers
when I'd send them on a mission and rob
their house yeah you know like did [__]
like that then as I got older when I
moved to Colorado I got Bolder and I got
busted I got a little Boulder and I got
busted and then when I got out I went
under the radar for a while and then I
went back to Jersey in 94 and I was okay
for a few months I'm not going to tell
you I was a saint but I hooked up with
some guys that were robbing like that
and I did like two or three when I was
out that's a complete different [__]
scam because I don't know what this
motherfucker's thinking yeah I don't
know what this guy's thinking
I don't know what this guy's thinking I
always want I always did the [__] that
was the least risk you know what I'm
saying like I knew that the security
guards in the mall couldn't touch me
because I worked at Hot Topic when I was
16 and they told us they were like yeah
you can call security security then has
to call the cops and I was like well can
we tackle somebody if they're [__] no
they could watch you and go all the way
into your car and all that [__] your
plate it's still a [__] nightmare to
shake cuz this guy wants to be a a
[__] cop yeah this guy wants to
really be a cop so whether he's 16 or
not he's going to try to deploy you or
stand in front of your [__] car and
try to Fe to run them over those [__]
people are crazy those m security people
they're crazy cuz they couldn't be real
cops so now they're [__] it's a
[__] nightmare they salute the flag
and they're on George Zimmerman that was
his mentality he wanted to be a [__]
[__] you guys have no [__] idea I
have a friend that thinks he's a [__]
you know please it's a [__] nightmare
dog so I I get it that the same guy who
owned the pizzeria that would have a
steal sneakers and golf clubs this is
how my relationship ended with him
because I was delivering pizzas for him
but then I started making more money
doing scams for him he was like I want
to close my Pizzeria he was like he like
but I want to collect the insurance so
he was like I'm going to give you guys
$55,000 each to a 17-year-old kid dude
$5,000 is I mean it sounds like a
[__] million dollars it is it is
Jesus Christ dude 175 i' had never even
thought about that much money before I'm
going to give you guys $5,000 each come
in d d this place in lighter fluid and
gasoline just [__] light it on fire
and that's that and I mean we went as
far as we we went we had the lighter
fluid we hid it behind the pizzeria
while we were working me and this kid
James and we hid the lighter fluid
behind it we were going to [__] D the
whole kitchen the electrical box boom
and uh one of the cook saw us hiding the
lighter fluid and he was like oh what's
that oh I don't know and that made me so
paranoid yeah you had done that I was
like I was like I can't you're on low
that's a low and Order episode that's it
one person SE anything looks suspicious
no saage
light
fluid
fluid that's [__] hilarious write
that down go I think it's time to get an
arrest warrant from Mr LS Gomez yeah dud
he also you break the commercial lisis
is in the [__] room with Jay OAS and
dropping knowledge and [__] get up Louis
Gomez Jerry all back kicks the table and
[__] and the Puerto Rican the Benjamin
Brad handcuff you and [__] you're under
arrest for arson Mr what are you talking
about I wasn't at the pizzaeria last
night tell that to the Cook we had a
[__] we had the plan was we were 18
actually cuz I remember we used to go to
the bar it was an 18 and over bar that I
ended up uh working in security at
eventually but the we were going to have
a [__] um you know an alibi and we
were going to go to the bar and we was
going to act the plan we going to act
like crazy and wild and let everyone see
us crazy drunk but we weren't going to
be drinking we're going to act like we
were just [__] hammered and let
everybody see us we were going to sneak
out jump in the car was about a 15minute
drive from nyak to West a about 20
minutes and we're going to [__] light
this place on fire zip back and that was
the whole plan we were [__] we had
The Alibi oh they were crazy they were
partying all night the these guys they
were [__] they were hammered there's
no way they could have left it's laow
and Order ladies did they look like they
could be going to light of
fire no say
did anybody see them buy a drink did
anybody see them buy a drink I didn't
really see Tommy he kept Whispering his
I think they call him Lou Lou Gomez yeah
Lou Gomez he sold me a comedy ticket oh
[__] dude I there's so many little
things like that where it could have
[__] destroyed my life my God it
destroys your life bro that's it could
have Fu I could have been that's 15
[__] years and and you start at
Rikers and they put you through the
[__] system and then you violate
because God knows
what happens that's a [__] oh my God
every morning I get up I go Lord thank
you thank you for not [__] involving
me I could have [__] been I mean de
who knows it's it's nuts how close it's
fun though it's fun good memories good
stories let me give some shout outs here
water boxer Curtis Stillwell shroom
Factory Crystal Johnson Lon doggy Pamela
Grant Buffalo Comedy my main man Bobby
lingis and John fent trro
also my man Matt Baker up there in
Bakersfield
BJJ the [__] he taught me is working you
understand me that's it man no listen I
give thanks every [__] day and I give
thanks I didn't really get creepy when I
started to get creepy I got arrested and
I thank God he put that in my [__]
Journey they you know but I loved it and
I learned to steal when I went as a kid
to 148th Street
those kids stole to survive but to hang
with them I had to steal and even though
my family had money I had to steal and
it became fun for me and then you know
what happened I heard stories about my
father I heard that my father hung out
with like a really good pickpocket he
was the best pickpocket in Cube and all
this [__] so in my in my head it broke
me down morly like if my dad can hang
out with a pickpocket you know what I'm
saying like like that's why I don't like
you kids hearing about the [__] you did
because now it Chang is there it's okay
to steal your friend Nikki
stole I know that's why when you open
those [__] stories up right away
everything changes because you hung out
with Nick and he stole you know it's so
rough how I have to raise my daughter
now you have to raise your son you know
we look a little deeper you know I tell
me and Lee have conversations about
being a parent how I always want to be
home between three and six because
that's when I [__] got in the most
trouble that's when you know if there
was somebody home maybe things would
have changed and they monitored me a
little bit more you know and this is the
[__] you look at because of the [__] you
did how easy you're telling me these
stories at 16 to normal people this
[__] was still you know he was
still jerking off with his little dick
and breathing heavy at 16 oh I was
jerking off everywhere know you but I
was also stealing please don't get me
stunning and jerking off you had my
blood pressure up all high that's why I
had to take the other
star uh just the thought of thing that
and that you could be honest about them
because this days I I think of [__] I
see people on Facebook and I feel guilty
you know yeah but you got to put it
behind you it's not like we ended up in
jail yeah and uh you know what I feel
more guilty about um when I first
started stealing when I was maybe and I
I almost like learned my lesson for a
little while I was probably like seven
um no maybe a little older eight or nine
and my my buddy Mike and his brother
Serge we would go to the just the
parking lots and it was simple see what
cars were open whatever's open clear out
the change every once in a while you get
a $20 bill in in the dashboard or
whatever um we used to just do that
regularly like that was we you know
after school we'd meet up like all right
let's go make five 10 bucks for the day
you know and uh those kids this like one
of the most guilty I've ever felt in my
entire life they ended up I was I was
I'm Puerto Rican and Italian but I grew
up in a really big like white trash area
where I grew up and there was a lot of
white kids who would like beat me up and
call me a [__] and a [__] and throw
rocks at me and um I always really
wanted their acceptance and all my
family was white I was raised by you
know Italian Irish people so I I've
always had weird like racial identity
issues I grew up listening to like heavy
metal music and I played in a band I
used to have long hair and an eyeliner
like I was in I was in Maryland Manson
and [__] I was like I was a [__]
weird kid right so I uh yeah I would
[__] uh these kids that I knew these
two kids who the one kid Mike you know
to this day is actually a really good
friend of mine um him and his brother
ended up just WIP yourself on
fire I got on camera it's Hitler's
[Laughter]
birthday [__] suck but the two the two
like dark skinned Hispanic that I hung
out with they went and they robbed this
other white kid from my neighborhood's
car and took the the car phone out of it
this one car phones were like [__]
crazy expensive like and then they keyed
up the side of the car but this kid was
a [__] he was the [__] worst
person in the neighborhood he was like
the wimpiest of all of them but he was
the biggest instigator so [__] this kid
this kid was a piece of [__] this kid
Ryan um but my buddy Mike told me he was
like K me and my brother we [__]
keyed this kid's car and we took the the
phone and like a [__] idiot dude I
was want of the acceptance of these
[__] white kids I went and told that
kid Ryan that they I ratted my friends
out this is like the probably the most
guilty I've ever felt about anything in
my entire life I ratted my two friends
out to some [__] kid who
would call me a [__] in a
[__] and that's that like [__] me up
that was like the worst thing I've ever
done in my entire life I could steal I
could almost set a place on fire I could
beat somebody up that's the thing that
[__] me up the
most I'm sorry DG it's all
right now what set you off the most I'm
sorry D we got [__] up things happen I
cannot tell that story again in its
completion she heard it no I heard it I
heard it
you know man I ratted my friends out
that was what [__] me up first off you
know life moves on and you always get a
second chance and you always got a
second chance to prove yourself and some
people don't want you to prove yourself
and some people do and you do whatever
you need to do to [__] make the ship
smooth I [__] robbed change from Cars
when I was 31 years old I did it every
night to get home from 57th and 12th I
sold cars down there yeah so at 8 I
creep into the [__] service Bay and
just steal change and I get those tokens
and those passes to go with the bridge
and tunnel and I go up to and sell them
to the cab drivers up at Washington
Heights by Port Authority up there I had
to scam down how ashamed was I I steal
chains to get home and then when I
couldn't steal chains I call my friend
Darren Rego and he come over and pick me
up and take me into the city we do open
mics like the com strip and like May and
he wasn't a comic but he want me to be
in the city with him CU he'd go get Coke
and I could speak Spanish so we
everything always works itself out you
know what I'm saying so got a couple
bumps he drive me to go do comedy and
then he drive me back over the tunnel of
the [__] Bridge so I still change out
of [__] cars how embarrassing is that
31 years old how [__] embarrassing is
that so you do things man and that's
you're here you get a second chance
that's what you do from now and this is
the [__] you work on your kids this is
the [__] you instill in your kids and
you don't want them to someday your
son's going to hear this yeah you know
and uh he's going to have to make a
decision whether it was okay and not and
hopefully he'll turn out to be a [__]
cop yeah you know like just be a this
Cas yeah absolutely man yeah you know
well it's all bad parenting that's what
it is you know I I a shitty mom my dad
wasn't there that was it you know what
it's like to take change out of a car
and then like maybe find like a a
booklet and now Becky in these days
these booklets
were 94 I forget what it was to go over
the tunnel you know the bridge $8 maybe
you know let's pretend it's 16 now
correct no no no it was way cheaper than
that because when I started driving when
I was 16 it was four this is that was
97 I'm estimating 98 99 no this is 94
four bucks three four bucks it's
definitely not more than four so if you
bought the book it was 10 rides for 40
bucks oh that's right yeah you could buy
you could buy the books yeah so I'd find
those in people's cars and I'd take the
whole thing and sell them for half price
so there was eight tickets left whatever
I get 16 [__] dollars but some nights
those $16 I go home with like 90 bucks
and right around the corner from where
I'd sell them was a Coke spot and they
sold grams of cut Coke for $25 and grams
of utcut coke for
$35 and you walked into the apartment
and the guy would call you like I'll you
that means milk swallower right and then
he Dominican guys and there'd be two
guys in the [__] room and they have
two little bags of coke with a little
tiny electronic scale and they give you
a taste of each of it and you do a
little bump and sit across the table you
gain the cash and some nights I go I go
over and you could they would sell you a
grand and a half you know they give you
a deal and I would get a Grandam and a
half and walk I was so cheap I would
walk over the [__] Lincoln uh the
bridge the George Washington
Bridge and at the end of everything here
you on 3: in the morning snorting coke
sweating and all a sudden it dawned on
you that you rubb the [__] change out
of a [__] somebody these car and you
know how bad you [__] feel it's not
bad enough that you're out of coke now
and you're coming down and you want to
shoot yourself you just realized what
you did to get to this place and that
was the worst thing about the coke with
me like that's the end of the night how
bad it was you didn't do drugs so no I
mean I I [__] with him but I didn't I
didn't get I I luckily I kind of [__]
saw a lot of people I had an
ex-girlfriend who was a major heroin
addict my mom she committed suicide with
Heroin so it's like yeah you know it's
fine uh fun no no fine it's not fun I
said well actually it was probably a fun
way to go if you're going to go I think
overdosing on heroin is probably better
than [__] slicing your wrist at a
bathtub no
you got interesting life Lou Gomez you
got to write a book yeah you got to
shoot a movie and you and Patterson
[__] sorry about that that was like a
worm in my [__] throat why why do you
think you guys both went into sales
after that oh you were in sales too what
else you going to do yeah you know I see
these [__] on TV I I got no
skills like I'm know what the [__] you
got you know I know the [__] I can do
yeah but I know a little bull [__] I
could do you know and over the years you
you know when you're 24 who who wants to
work on a roof for 12 bucks an hour I
can't imagine what they pay you now with
the you know with the you know all the
minority work workers out there I can't
imagine what it's like out there to be
out there fighting for your [__] life
now but eventually you got to give into
doing something illegal somewhere what
did you
sell first thing I saw was newspapers
subscriptions oh my [__] god Joey are
we the same person Joey my first job in
my life I'm not making it up cuz I have
fans that know I'm not bullshitting I
used to sell newspaper subscriptions for
the Rockland Journal News in in parking
lots of sh like shop right you go people
hey I want to win a bike I'm in a
contest could you sign up for this it
was a free subscription and I would get
$5 for every subscription I got and I
was making when I was 11 making like 400
bucks a week $350 a week more than my
mom and my mom was like what the [__]
and that's I dude that's [__] crazy
to me that that was your first job
people have no idea the importance of
belly to belly
sales people don't because without that
you're really
not what's that word that Rambo used
they used on Rambo that he was
extendable Expendable Expendable if you
don't if you're an engineer and you
can't add belly to belly sales to your
resume you're Expendable [__] if you're
an IT guy and you can't add belly to
belly sales to your repertoire you're
Expendable [__] if you're a [__]
painter and you can't add the belly to
belly sales you're Expendable you will
always be [__] Expendable if you
can't do both those jobs belly to belly
mean you're actually Clos yourself face
to face you you belly to belly sales is
basic I don't listen I love computers
and I love what it does but I'm a belly
to belly guy I don't want you texting me
I don't want you [__] bothering me
you want to talk to me you come [__]
see me and you sell me you know don't
text me you're having a sale on t-shirts
you know I'm an old school guy come tell
me why I got to buy your [__] t-shirt
you you said an appointment you're not
selling them over the Fone you set an
appointment I believe in all that [__]
it's true1 you want to get them running
your face I don't give a [__] if you go
back to doing what you're doing but you
always have that to fall back on yeah
that's why I tell and I've told it a
thousand times if I'm still alive and my
da my daughter's 18 I'm going tell her
go right to [__] Ford dealership and
sell cars for a year start there it'll
change your life it'll change your
[__] life one year you will not be
the same person you will look at life at
18 from a [__] savagery well that's
why when I was selling Comedy Club
tickets I mean you're talking belly to
belly man that's belly to belly belly
belly it's you're meeting a stranger and
you're going boom it's four steps in
every sales process you stop them you
engage them with a smile you can get
questions find out a little bit about
them inform them about your product and
you close them you bring them to one
second Lee you and I had a conversation
today about
sponsorship right and what did I say to
you I don't even want you to sell them
what was the word I said I wanted you to
engage them get them that's it that's it
sales if you don't engage this
[__] that's it just engage him
on this time I want you to make a
personal not you're not even going to
sell him I don't even want you to go in
there like you're going to sell them
that's two steps away I want you to
engage them just engage them get them in
hand-to hand combat hand-to hand combat
is I don't that's the [__] Master
reality right here get him to reply to
your email see I was an Expendable
comedian to until I learned hand toand
combat till I learned hand toand combat
I was a struggling comic even with
movies till one day I said you know what
I got to get in there and get down and
dirty and that's what doesn't make you
an Expendable anything yep cuz you can
apply that phly anything to anything so
it's a beautiful [__] concept and I
stress it daily like you got to [__]
I tell Lee Lee's trying Lee's trying and
I'm trying to you know Lee it's a high
the only way you really dig in is you
just got to invent people to call I've
never had like I I was a server but I
never had a sales job really so I this
is brand new to me but it's still look
when you're when you're if you're a good
server the people who are making the
most money oh are the people who are
engaging the people in the best way who
are getting them to actually you connect
with them and you get some sort of
emotion out of them so the people that
are my my son's mother she stopped her
she was an office manager for a video
game publishing company she just wanted
to work a few days a week because she
you know she had the baby she went back
to waiting tables and it's like that's
the one thing I I would tell her she was
like yeah it's not even the prettiest
girl who's a waitress it's not the girl
who's taking the most tables the ones
who are getting the most tips and making
the most money are the people who are
you see the people laughing at their
table or they're smiling or there
there's just some sort of connection
going on Beyond you giving them their
food so I mean that's like a philosophy
that like in every aspect of life you
know even we're talking about picking up
chicks and it's being a game of numbers
dude that's that's sales philosophy you
figure out your ratio boom I'll close
one out of over how many people I could
take Louis Gomez okay give him a car
give him5 $800
suits okay give them the shiniest shoes
in town with a white shirt
with gold collar links and I could walk
Lou Gomez into any sales
staff anywhere in the country and within
a year Lou Gomez will be [__]
threatening the top two guys in that
Corporation
once he figures him out and learns how
to engage him and brings him back to the
ballpark because what happens is we take
ourselves out of the ball park see Louis
and myself have the skill that got you
covered the sale skill we learned we
learned on the street that's a
tremendous that's a tremendous cushion
that's walking on a [__] tight RPP
every day that's not like oh so he
didn't buy the sneakers Jesus I'll have
to get him next time he comes in for
those Nikes no no no no no no no no no
you know that's a complete different
[__] PTO when you got to go out to
eat and you got to sell four nickel bags
you know whatever that's it that's it
and you got to tell this guy why your
weed is better than
hers 10 feet from me I'd buy anything
from [__]
Becky but he's going to talk tell me
without insulting Becky why his weed
even though it's the same weed that's
his cushion those guys you can't replace
I could walk him into any [__] any
[__] Corporation this guy could sell
[__] tepps yeah tepps my last job I
was selling gym memberships one year at
equinox High gym memberships I would
never you know dealing with [__]
millionaires coming into the gym and
send them $200 a month gym memberships
but they can go to New York Sports Club
and get a $30 month gym membership but
it was never about the money it was
never you you know once you learn how to
once you learn the sales process and you
have a belief in the sales process then
even the NOS become fun the whole
process is part it's just part of a game
I'm looking for no that's it give me
another not yeah but I'm engaged okay
that's the same
thing I'm engaged okay yeah watch this
watch my [__] magic watch I come at
you with this [__] curb ball watch
this one and it it's just amazing it
applies to [__] every level yeah of
it that's a great idea though to have
your daughter work in sales for a year
to to just to understand that you know
and but look it's not for everybody not
not everybody can sell people you have
to I want them to respect it yeah so
later on in their life when they do move
forward they understand the importance
of that cell if they think of opening up
a company they're going to know that it
all starts right there everything else
is [__] [__] it all starts right
there you know it all starts right there
whatever marketing attack you got has to
start right there yeah some people they
can't you know some people can't it's I
think why people can like a lot of good
comedians have that ability to be able
to sell and it's one of the reasons why
me and my son's mother broke up is
because she's so practical and you know
the idea she needs a safety net like in
my head I'm going the safety that is
you're not going to starve you're going
to eat you're going to figure out a way
to feed your kid you're going to figure
out a way to pay your rent you know
almost a belief in the intangible like
to do comedy and really give it your all
and [__] say I want to be a standup
comedian which is just it's so stupid if
you think about what it is like we're
just [__] saying words and we're
expecting people to give us money for it
get the [__] out of here that's crazy
that's a crazy there's that talk about
being in having an intangible thing to
sell it's just our [__] thoughts and
words that's bananas and you have to
almost have this weird belief in
yourself and confidence and and you have
to be able to Envision this gold so
wholeheartedly that you give yourself to
it and that's why I was always good at
sales because I could just I could say
all right my goal is you know 140 units
this month I if I truly believed I was
going to get there all the other [__]
would just kind of come together you
know and I think not a lot of people can
Envision something like that it's that's
why I take a very special person most
sales people fail you know if you go to
any the sales is always the highest
turnover it's just non-stop new people
boom or they move to somewhere where the
grass is greener yeah what happens to
sales people is for a couple years you
get confused and you keep moving to
where the grass is greener the grass is
green well my friend sells computers no
my friend sells blow degrees no you have
to come over and sell alarms we're
giving them away we're making six
figures and you keep running for the
same and at every place you go to You're
a medium salesman I did it for years you
become a medium salesman do you have to
really know the product though cuz like
I I don't know nothing about I don't
know anything about cars nothing yeah
that's the weirdest thing cuz they're
going to give you what they want that's
that's when you engage them they fall
into your trap yeah it's yeah of course
let's go get the brochure what are you
looking for they're going to tell you
when I used to sell gym memberships and
that I mean I used to make I made six
figures selling [__] gym memberships
right that was my last day job and uh
you know people would come in and hey
cool what are you here for they're just
going to tell you everything they want
wow we have that perfect I can't believe
you'd show up here how perfect is that
that's so that's nut we have exactly
what you're looking for so I mean any
that's like a sales trick that's why it
doesn't take people a year to learn the
ins and outs of any product the
salesperson comes in with they do a week
of training a week later boom they're
right there and then you're going to
learn what people's triggers are that's
the best what trigger me trigger what
gets people going like about that
product you're going to find out why
they're coming in specifically for prod
the buying signs and the whole and it
just becomes you become a machine oh you
got well I you're looking for safety I
know you you just study it you just it's
such a beautiful [__] thing when you
get into it it's just doing it for 10
years and being consistent you have to
know when to take vacations and so and I
know you haven't done it for a while but
um how much money have like a $20,000
card does a Salesman get
it all depends you're working on profit
so you buy a car the car the car I could
sell the car for
162 okay 162 is what I got in the car
I'll take anything over 172 Le go get me
my [__]
money okay I need a thousand over
[__] book you know what a thousand
over book gets you it's a mini deal you
get $250
flat that's what you
get as a Salesman if you get like a
th000 no let's say you get over 25% then
they give you like 30% so let's say you
go back in there and you get the guy up
to
7600 right now you got $1,400 profit and
you go back there all you go go back in
there one more time and get me 300 yeah
and you got to go back in there and get
another [__] 300 that's how you eat
got a [__] living and you got to go
explain the guy why that car is worth
3400 but I I take good good salesman
appreciate when somebody's selling and
they're really good I love it I [__]
love it my dick's getting hard keep on
going I love it I love it I love it I
get pissed off when I go somewhere with
money and I watch how they treat me it
destroys my inside you B customer
service I walk out of that Furious
threaten a [__] McDonald's employee
for bad customer service it's crazy I'm
about to give you my money and you're
going to be [__] rude you're going to
have bad customer service you're not
going to actually go through the process
of what you have to do in order to take
the money out of my hand I've walked out
of so many places like restaurants where
they they have like an attitude when you
first walk in the door I'm like [__]
this whole place I'll walk right out and
I'll go next door to a place that has
less good reviews that has less good
food because I think customer service
and and just right off the top just
having that connection with people
because you're spending money in their
establishment I think it's so important
I think it's loss in big cities La is
different you guys are all [__]
friendly as [__] dude New York I mean
dude they [__] listen these
[__] won't take your money what
go to a vitamin store yeah go in there
just and
I've never been treated how I've been
treated the last 10 years in this
country across the [__] country but
this place is the worst well with like
uh going into places how they don't even
talk to you Hi how are you let us know
if we can help you that's it that's it
you look at them and go you dumb
[__] I got $300 bills I want to
spend my money I want to spend my money
now I'm not even going to spend you
you're so [__] stupid you're so
[__] stupid but I'm not even going to
[__] spend it I went to the fat man
store last week
up there into panga Canyon by the
Jiu-Jitsu
house and I me and my wife had a few
hours we got to go up there by two let's
just shoot up there see what the fat man
store got I went up there the guy wasn't
bad cuz I walked in he welcomed me good
morning do you know what you're looking
for I said not really I just want to
look around he said no worries if you
have your eye on something let me know
he watched what I had in my hand he ran
over to the clearance rack and he said
see if you like this I said I don't like
that but he goes there's some other [__]
I went over there and I busted the shirt
out tonight to take the Buffalo he got
me a clearance shirt from then on I
walked with the guy yeah I got this i
got this I got that he asked me for my
fat man Card discount card I threw it at
him and everything was hunky dory he
worked me the right way he wasn't
pressur [__] that the pressy
drive me [__] crazy there's a way to
apply pressure but later and then you
have to think you know what what we have
to work with it yeah those [__]
drive me crazy but if you see somebody
doing the actual sales process the right
way it just makes me go like I [__]
appreciate it you know I really do I I
will I will buy from a good salesperson
even if I don't even really want to buy
it that bad I'm like if I can recognize
let's say I want to buy something and
I'm going to come back you know later on
even on the phone you buy like [__]
you dealing with customer service or
you're buying airline tickets or
whatever you know I if somebody does the
things the right way I'm just just as a
point and I'll let them know I was like
you're a really good salesperson I was
like if they if they got a man R I'll
tell the manager you got a really good
salesperson right there they understand
how to do
this so I went and got the suits at the
Hollywood Suit place and the guy was
good but he was a little bit like too
like he made me like do the Yelp in
front of him which was a little bit
weird what but he did the uh he like he
actually got me like we like we there's
like a level of Suits you're supposed to
get and he may he got me to go on one up
on a level so I been a little bit more
but he was good it was in and out in
like 10 minutes but you're a nice guy I
think I could sell you anything oh yeah
I'm I feel like I could [__] I could
s you a size 32
pants and tell you don't worry you'll be
there in 3 weeks you know what I'm
saying I think that even the art of
waitressing is salesmanship yeah like
when you go to a high-end why do I have
to go to a high-end restaurant to bump
into a [__] good waiter and 50% of
them are [__] droops anyway but it's
different for me because there there's
no guarantee that they're going to buy
at like a store or like a dealership at
a restaurant they're there to eat so you
just tell them oh like when I when I
worked at Legal Seafoods I didn't like
lobster but oh Lobster's delicious it's
the most but I can tell you you didn't
believe that though no I didn't well no
I didn't and you might as well tell him
the truth I don't e lob app [__]
idiot always tell him the truth I i' way
Fu up cuz they bought into that this
well not yeah well not every time but
yeah I you that's what you you have to
cuz most people want to try Lobster
that's why they're there's cockroach of
the sea you feel that you feel that
stuff all right yes you want a little no
no no I can't Joey you take no no no I
can't I Wing look Jo I can't it's 420
look what you want I'm going to get
baked and then it's I'm going to feel
one more little wing my guilt my guilt
is going to kill me what guilt my guilt
guilt dude I was drinking a half a
bottle of whiskey at night and smoking
Morning Noon T night I'd be hanging out
with my kid if I ran out of weed I have
to think about how I'm going to go find
more weed who's drinking whiskey you's
just eat little tip of the star Twinkle
Twinkle Little
Star wonder who you are I can't man I
can't just a little bit more you you
going to leave here you you you got one
gun you might as well carry two you know
what I'm saying you want too eat another
little wing then me you'll finish that a
little tiny F it's 420 [__] there we up
long time let do that [__] give the rest
of that Del he's going deep go ahead Le
breaking go ahead Lee you're going go
ahead so what no it's not a th yes he
just at 100 what a thousand I don't know
what any of the [__] means am I going to
get baked now le Lee this is it Lee
you're breaking your own record that's
it it's 420 this is it this dude I it's
funny I was like that when I walked in I
was like that picture does not look like
Lee and now that picture looks just
like go Lee go what the [__] hand
go go Lee take the picture it's over
there you go Lee take the press the
button oh God you're fine chew that
[__] out where's the water make
sure you're dehydrated over I'll leave
some go ahead you're going deeping it
just sitting M wait you know how many
milligrams I ate before I got here
please if anybody's scared it's
me goad swallow the thing you're going
you're going look at Lee is baked [__]
yeah this is it Lee this is it you're
done for the we what are you doing
tomorrow I'm not going to say
[Laughter]
Paula nothing now what do you got
tomorrow nothing
eat the [__] thing where's the water
drink it please what are you
embarrassing yourself I can't believe
you sold the newspaper subscriptions
that's crazy what I did was I got a
[__] paper out yeah I was one of
those guys that got a paper out and
after like and it was a far away paper
like I walked the 46 Street it's a hill
mhm I still remember carrying those
things but they gave me a route that the
kid got like he quit it was like a great
route at one time and then they're like
this was a great route what happened the
kid beat it up like he was mean and [__]
so I took that route it took me like 60
days and I doubled it I had everybody
get in that paper one day they called me
and like we want you to take over the
Zone wow I was like 12 bro I played
basketball I don't even think I smoked
dope then I was like Allure to
it I think I tried it for a few weeks I
think I won two or four weeks like the
zones of going knocking on doors and S
on them door I did it door to door yeah
we did it door to door too and this
Jewish woman called the cop me and this
black kid we [__] knocked on This
Woman's door this [__] [__] Jewish
chick hidic Jew in [__] Spring Valley
New York dude we're going door to door
just we're trying to make an honest
living we're kids you know what I'm
saying like this kid's may be 12 I'm 11
always remember one thing okay and don't
ever get confused I'm not here to judge
nobody yeah when you're trying to make
an honest living you can't show up with
a black
kid all right I'm not even racist and
I'm telling you this right off the bat I
don't care if you're selling cookies or
Catholic Bibles door to door yeah you
show up with a black kid I'm looking out
the peephole and just saying I don't
want nothing yeah well maybe that was my
fault yeah you can't show up with a this
woman but here's here's why she's [__]
up right we're like ding dong she
[__] uh she had just gotten in from
maybe shopping now the more I think
about it we really did look Shady we
look like we followed her home from the
store you can't open up that [__]
door dude at that time the Jews were at
war with the blacks remember that [__]
yeah in Spring Valley yeah yeah but they
well here's here's what's [__] up up
though cuz she [__] comes to door
she's like all right hold on so we're
like all right cool so you know we give
her a little pitch hey we're with the
rock Journal newspaper she's like she
pokes her head out the window we're like
yeah we're selling newspaper
descriptions she's like all right hold
on I'll be right out we're like uh all
right you know wait like 10 minutes Bing
Bong like hey miss you can come out
she's like yeah no no I'm coming I'm
going to be right there we're going to
talk cops [__] show up a [__]
minute later they pull their guns out I
we're kids dude this is crazy they pull
their [__] guns out and we're like
what the [__] and you know were [__]
they were shitty to us we were you know
Black and Hispanic kid in this Jewish
neighborhood we look like we're up to no
good but you know the reality was she
kept us there she like we weren't we
would have hey no I'm not interest
that's what the cop says to you 911 who
who was there there's a Hispanic and a
and a [__] I don't know how to say it
he's said a schwat what are they doing I
don't know they're at my they're at my
door you know what I'm saying and all a
sudden well can you hold them there the
offices are right around the corner I'll
be right there yeah okay ma'am and next
thing you know whoop whoop and there you
are [__] stand there with [__]
darkkey MC Reynolds in a Jewish [__]
neor what you're lucky you didn't get
shot you and your friend yeah it was uh
that yeah we did it door to door but the
most success I had was in in the parking
lots just because it was free people
didn't even have to give us money sign
up for eight weeks free the Rockland
Journal News $5 yeah yeah yeah that's
that's the way to go yeah cuz they
didn't cancel their subscriptions and
then they'd build them they never they'd
make it so they because they were all
scam artists it was all [__] scams
back before the internet before you
could yel somebody and give them a bad
review it was like what are they going
to do how are they going to we're going
to build them cuz we've been sending the
[__] paper to their door they had
write in a letter or some [__] to cancel
the subscription because nobody would
answer the phones and that was that and
they knew they'd make more than $5 off
of each subscription they say yes to I
got I'm sorry couldn't you just fake it
and like go through the phone book yeah
we did that all the time we did that in
the winter time when we were doing it
that's what we would do yeah [__] was
going to people just cuz by the time our
boss has figured out that it wasn't a
real person cuz they called to confirm I
guess to make sure they they got it or
whatever I never ordered the paper hold
on one second Jane did you order the
paper no I didn't order the paper Tommy
you order the paper no I didn't order
the paper we didn't order no [__]
paper don't call here no more all right
but you know you put a fake number you
put whatever and you know you you they'd
get they' take the commissions back from
you but that's why everyone wants to get
fired in the winter CU you just go and
hang out in McDonald's you just play
[__] the video games at the local
arcade or whatever but yeah I mean I was
because I was so poor it was a it was a
good thing in a weird way because I
became very like industrious you know
what I'm saying I'm like I'm like the
guy who you know I produce all my I
don't trust somebody like him to [__]
produce my [__] I make sure that I have
my hands in everything um you know I I'm
I'm kind of like [__] obsessive with
like making sure my shit's the way you
know that I want it done but it was from
a young age I remember when I was like
seven the first time I ever cared about
making money cuz i' always do like a
lemonade stand or you know you'd go
you'd go shoveling snow door too in the
suburbs you know um cuz you know little
old ladies can't shovel their walkways
so you make five 10 bucks or whatever
but there was a guy who died in my
neighborhood and his family I guess they
you know they couldn't take all of his
furniture and horeshit that he had in
his house so they put it all out on the
curb um just for the garbage or whatever
so me and this other kid Nick Gully we
took all of the furniture that they put
out like everything like really nice
[__] like a nice leather couch like a
nice like wooden chest and we moved it
over to my yard and we had a yard sale
while my was at work one day and we were
[__] we were just getting ripped off
by adults the couch leather couch $5 I
was like yeah five okay this dude
[__] we were cleaned out in like two
hours because they were like they were
they they were actually ripping off
little kids in a weird way they should
have given us more money but uh I
remember that was like the first time I
ever was like I like making money I like
like going out and kind of like earning
money and I I almost became like I mean
it wasn't always scams it was it was a
lot of times it was just like I always
worked you know what I'm saying I used
to sweep when I was 11 after I I did
that job I started working at a hair
salon sweeping up the hair in the salon
and uh getting all the girls lunch I
used to jerk off in the salon too to the
girls cuz they were all hot yeah
disgusting come on this is where we this
that's where the fork in the road is for
me and Joey got a lot in common but just
jerking off in public he's just not into
it Louis Gomez you're an interesting guy
CU you're with people we don't exist no
more we're called Hustlers yeah you your
mind's always gone horrible way to
[__] live yeah way to live but your
mind's always gone mhm like I could put
like that and that's where I learned
from drug dealers I would put them
together I'd be with them for they watch
them for two days and I know where they
were hiding their [__] when they went to
pick it up who was watching it you know
you just figure my mind's always moving
like that it moves like that for comedy
yeah that's why once we took our mind
and reprogrammed it to apply to
something positive we would be
successful because we had been pseudo
successful all along it was just my
personal habits that would that took me
down the [__] that took me down all
along I made money over the years I
don't know what I made but I I know I
think back in my lifestyle in 85 I did
not have a [__]
job I did not have a job I took a job
like in April to [__] uh with a
hottie and he had was building a house
house in Fort Lee Linhurst or something
and I would take the bus because the
house was only going to be like they
were only going to be there till like
the second week of June and I just was
just taking a chance one day and I knew
I had to leave [__] Jersey they were
closing the doors on me I had already
robbed a ton of those gas stations I
owed some drug dealers money they you
know people had seen me in the city
drinking at bars and [__] you know so I
knew eventually I was going to get
[__] na and I got a call from a
friend of mine that said said that his
attorney had a check for
me from a phony [__] scam I did like
I fell on my shoulder and [__] like that
one those things and this guy was the
[__] like he would go to Beck Joey I'm
so sorry man I'm going to die if I don't
piss right now go go ahead go ahead no I
feel bad to cut off your story man yeah
I'm really I feel really and I want to
hear this goad hurry up take your time
but hurry up F over over there Lee how
you feeling
[__] I'm doing great now we'll do
one of the sponsors real quick here let
me get the
Sheets first
off my number one [__] on
it.com supplying the juice you're like
Joey what's the juice shroom Tech Sport
and shroom Tech immune hemp Force
protein shakes the Mike doce almond
banana protein the new protein that Lee
already [__] devoured in two weeks
cuz it was so [__] yummy for your
tummy you understand me that's what H it
does for you they also have kettle bells
and vest and a bunch of great stuff that
I can't describe and that would just be
bullshitting if I tried to go to hit.com
right now that's a most important thing
you're just sitting there by your
[__] desk go to on it check out the
Great Deals they have available for you
especially the supplements I mean they
got everything in there the tea
supplements just take a look you like
anything put it in the drop box boom 10%
off what's the what's the code Church CH
you CH gets your 10% off your first
order delivered right to your house and
if you want this delivered to your house
on the Cycles get on the stay on it
program but I tell you what if you're
[__] you know working out you're
trying to take care of yourself on it
has something for you [__] go to
on it.com and press in church
chch and get 10% off your hon a deal
listen uh I went to this uh seminar a
few weeks ago on breathing and then she
did it Dr bisa came on the podcast and
all this breathing stuff that she uh
subscribed which is [__] working to I
did great to which is
working about that yeah get in there
brother the root of it is when you're
sitting there is that you're breathing
and you you you kind of going into a
meditative State cuz you you're
breathing out you're breathing in you're
moving your pelvis even if you're
sitting there you could breathe this way
and what she wants you to do is to get
the lower half of your body breathing in
fact you got to go to that girl's 10
Planet class she said because she's
incorporating all that breathing [__] in
her in her yoga but back to it it goes
hand in hand with meditation now let's
be honest most of your problems start
with your mind fear anger stress anxiety
depression sleeplessness they begin in
your head and they can wreck your life
but it doesn't have to be that way you
can make a major difference in just 10
minutes a day you understand me 10
minutes a day this change comes through
guided meditation with a new headspace
app headspace is meditation Made Simple
simple bam it's guided meditations you
listen to whenever you want wherever you
want right on your phone computer on
your tablet you could be on a flight you
could be meditating instead of sitting
there looking at disgusting stuff like
people you know what I'm saying
meditation is rooted in thousands of
years of tradition with thousands
thousands of scientific studies that
show the positive effects like improving
focus and relationship Harmony and
decreasing anxiety and stress join over
4 million users already getting headp
space for free fre that's right now for
free do me a favor download the free
headspace app and begin their take 10
program for 10 days of guided meditation
at headspace.com Joey that's right to
experience the benefits of meditation in
your busy Modern Life so do me a favor
train your mind for a healthier less
stressed life start with your free trial
today right now today at headspace.com
joeey again that's headspace.com Joey
you will not be sorry sorry I've been
getting a few emails on this and it's
true it all goes back to breathing and
focusing your energies and if you want
to reference Andy pedom Ted Talk which
has over 5.5 million views it should
come up in the Google Andy pedom Ted
Talk Andy is the founder headspace and
the voice you hear on the app so again
go to headspace.com joeey and start your
free trial today and get the take 10
program how's that for you so what was I
talking about no talking about I have no
[__] idea I'm too high yeah got into
sales we got into
hustling the um scorebig oh we'll do
that after we're talking here we'll do
that at the end so we close it some you
always want to close it some you don't
to leave him a little something you know
what I'm saying P McGregor yeah we got
like uh three four a couple minutes and
[__] like that uh no you're an
interesting dude man you have nothing to
be ashamed about I think about being
ashamed some nights and I I go why yeah
why I redeem myself what's a redeeming
myself I'm a productive member of
society I pay taxes I don't Litter I
stopped R all ladies it's so funny like
I stopped lit I remember I I would just
throw a [__] gum yeah I did too [__]
is bad yeah Joe Rogan was the first
person who said you shouldn't litter it
I
watch my manager litter the it BS you it
bothers the [__] out of you I'm like
you're I was like you're an adult what
are you doing why you throwing your
[__] gum rapper on the floor you want
to throw a roach on the floor be my
guest
in the [__] Street there where the
cars run over and [__] like that there's
just so many things that you you don't
even know you think you're a productive
member Society until you really become a
and I haven't been a productive member
of society maybe like [__] seven
years the rest has been been a
destruction I've been well that's why
I'm trying to not smoke weed is because
I'm not a productive member of or I'm
much less of a productive member of
societ we got nothing to do with it if I
had more you got to kick it up a little
bit why we going to blame reer I'm not
blaming reer I'm
BL no weed is great for everybody Funk
don't blame the I'm not good when I will
when I you know that anxiety you feel in
life get [__] done all day I try to
smoke it away instead of doing the [__]
I got to do you know what I'm saying
like that's my body going hey dude you
need to [__] work you need to hustle
you need to get on TV you need to be
successful you need to give your son a
good life and then I'm like well you
know what let me get high so I don't
feel that and then I don't do what I
need to do let me explain something to
you you've been a hustle all your life
yeah you've been teeta totting on the SL
of society you love it but not really
God gave you a blessing weed balance
that all out for you yeah weed makes you
feel a little dirty and you ain't doing
nothing weed makes you feel like ate
somebody's [__] you don't even know I
just want if I can get a [__] I
promise you as soon as I'm successful I
will smoke weed every night it'll be
great it's like becoming a Catholic
after you know what I'm saying it's like
me giving you 10 million now you want to
go to church you hypocrite [__]
now you want to come back to you got 10
million where were you when you were
poor where were you when you needed it
you [__] believe me if I wouldn't get up
and just want to smoke all day long and
just [__] not do about smoking and
being productive at the same time I I
have had times where I have been but
it's like dude the way I feel now that
I'm not getting baked all day it's like
I'm [__] there I finished projects
dude I finish I mean I I I never would
finish a script I would always take me a
year to finish a [__] script now I'm
actually writing at a high level I'm I'm
I'm myself I can have a conversation
with you make eye contact as opposed to
[__] you know just getting in my head
I don't know man it was like uh it was
if it was [__] with you then give it
a breather that's it yeah it's [__]
it was [__] time you got to jump in the
Hudson River here's what I'll tell you
here's what I'll tell you this is a
commitment that I'm going to make cuz
I'm not going to smoke weed and I want
to commit something you're a good man I
got man at you I try to I try to you
know I'm trying to really do this the
right way when I come to LA with you
I'll eat a corner of a star that'll
that'll be what I it'll be when I'm with
Joey Diaz I'll take a [__] little
nibble of a star to get me [__] right
here cuz to be honest I feel right I
feel nice right now I don't feel tell
you how many [__] avoid this
what so I applaud you because you came
on here and you said you know what and
you told me your story and I appreciate
it but not
tonight not tonight if you were some
white dude from Iowa I accept it you're
from the same Hood we both drank the
same water listen I had my struggles too
and finally you just break down and go
this is what I'm going to do and this is
what I can't do when you come to church
you got to eat the Eucharist yeah right
or wrong right you go to church and sit
there like a [__] half a [__] you put
five in the basket but you're not going
to get something out of the deal not
even a blessing from the fall Body of
Christ [__] the body of Christ
same [__] thing this is the body of
Christ [__] St Lazaro showed up you
know how strong this is from Steve
Simone you have I grew up with a listen
I'm Cuban and I will have my friends
from grammar school calling tomorrow and
say what do you remember about my house
and they'll go that [__] six foot St
Lazaro in your [__] living
room so my mom was that Cuban let me see
this thing for a second let me tell you
what looks like Ari shafir does look
like Ari
shafir these dogs are supposed to be
Labs a black lab and a gold like a gold
lab okay and he's got scars all over him
and it's leprosy and these dogs licked
his leprosy away so he became their
patron saint they celebrate this guy in
Cuba on December
17th this is how deep my mom was she
bought this [__] a cape a purple
cape
right and it was wrapped around his
shoulders and then she said he's missing
something so she went and got a 14 carat
gold you want to talk about being a
SP cuz there's only two people who do
this type of [__] yeah and we'll just
say it right out SP and [__] yeah are
the only people that look at a saint in
the living room and go that [__]
needs
something you know he needs a 14 karat
gold [__] one of those things things
that shines around your head when you're
a saint so this [__] had a Halo
my mother had a Halo made for him and
the purple
cape and then they said [__] it he's
missing something else so they went and
got him a gold
train and then in front of him they'd
have bottles of wine with glasses with
cigars cuz on a certain day of the week
you got to go over light your [__]
cigar blow that s Lazaro and put the
cigar down you don't know I lived in
this house you don't know how many times
I ran on stairs and I [__] my pants you
had it took three people to carry this
[__] in the house the base alone
weighed like 300 lb yeah okay so you'd
have to pick them up and then take now
the [__] muletas came off the
the what do you call these
things the crutches we had the crutches
that came off from his arms and then his
arms came off then he carried him his
head stayed on
one night my [__] sophomore year in
September I have a
party and one of my buddies is upstairs
banging this chick and her boyfriend
comes looking for her and the guy was a
senior football player Eddie burelli
I'll never forget this came into my
living room he goes hey anybody see this
chick and everybody goes we don't know
nothing and she was upstairs with Louis
the
[__] she was upstairs with the only do
he was Dominican okay you grew up in
Jersey he was the only Dominican in 197
9 yeah he had an afro so those white
kids Dominican what's a Dominican he's a
[__] you know they didn't understand
they was so backwards Lou the [__] was
upstairs giving it to her Eddie
barelli's downstairs asking for where
she is and then all of a sudden the back
of his mind he goes where's Louis the
[__] and we go he left an hour ago he
goes I want to look around the
house and this thing was standing there
this thing of St Lazar there was a table
and there was a a patio door that you
opened up jersey style to you backyard
and they came in the
kitchen I'll never forget there was this
kid Chris Donovan he was redhead and he
had freckles so Denny Colangelo used to
call him the
Riddler oh my God you have no idea so
after everything Denny would say he go
what's the story we're going to go for
hamburgers you in you in Riddler you in
and Riddler so for a year he lived under
the riddle of rain and that night he
went over and he goes Eddie you can't
come into kok's house and of this [__]
so I advise you to go and Eddie Bry goes
what if I don't Chris Donovan turned
around and took one of the muletas and
he goes I'll break this over your
[__] head you step me
again and that was the end these
[__] looked at each other I was
[__] a pickle my heart was pounding
my mom was in Miami trying to sell her
property and I th threw a [__] party
and now they're going to break the
[__] m in my living room I will be
dead if if St Lazaro breaks are you you
[__] kidding me I will be dead and
they walked out of there and that was
the end of that
war get stressed out just thinking about
it how you doing uh Louis lam more
what's going on over there how's how's
it feel to eat [__]
920 Mig no it's not it's not a thousand
he ate like a little piece he ate two
tails don't don't throw him under the
[__] flame all right yeah I went
pretty hard he he went deep you know
into the murky Waters of the underworld
why you why you [__] that I ate 1,00 you
didn't know [__] thousand I ate like
1,00 today I had a bunch of samples
that's cool I'm how how was it you're
looking good though you get tacos no I
didn't want to get that for the tacos I
I was getting there they were cooking
the tacos and they were giving you
tickets for ice cream the place was
[__] packed they food trucks at them
Tommy Easter said they had the Grilled
Cheese Truck cheese truck I saw a
grilled cheese truck today with a line
like a block long is that like a big
thing out here oh yeah the [__]
Gentiles go crazy cuz in New York it's
the [__] shitty Halal street meat
there's a couple of them in Midtown by
the SiriusXM building nobody's smoking
dope though in the street no no no not
at all but no they're they're packed
just in general yeah in New York you
dude I [__] I got a ticket for I got
arrested dude I got arrested for [__]
smoking weed uh this why I can't go into
Canada cuz I've been arrested for
smoking weed too many times I went to
Montreal Comedy Festival this past year
I was like they let me I got a [__]
thing that I had to pay $200 for a
temporary residency Visa they're like
just listen don't get in trouble again
me Dave Smith and these two chicks right
side of a bar smoking a bowl these cops
came up to us this how [__] up cops
are to Hispanic people they don't even
know these guys didn't even give a [__]
this is how racist these cops were and
I'm not a guy that calls racism I'm I
get called racist I'm not a guy that's
out there going oh cops are [__]
racist dude this [__] cop he goes to
my buddy Dave they grabb the ball from
us he's like all right and he saw Dave
put the weed in his pocket he was like
do you have weed in that pocket right
there they was like nope he I'm going to
ask you one more time okay and this is
very important you answer this question
honestly do you have weed in that pocket
right there Dave's like nope he's like
oh you want to lie to me and then he
grabs me by my shoulder goes your
buddy's coming in with me boom and they
put the handcuffs behind me they let him
keep the [__] weed dude they brought
me in I got out in like four hours it
wasn't a big deal during the Montreal
comedy no no no this is in New York
after the fact oh Jesus oh dude during
the festival I would have [__] killed
me before you get before you showcase
but dude now I can't go back now I'm
done D with Canada over
weed unbelievable Lou Gomez I don't tell
this to anybody anytime you're in town
you're a guest on here you're I love it
you have just become family thing cuz
you blew my
mind you're the last of the M heans
thank God Lee saw some other guy Lee
thinks I'm making this [__] up in my
mind when I talk youever smell your hand
that smells like
ass it's my left hand it doesn't you
know what I'm saying two hours you did
today yeah but I went home and took a
shower I did a thousand things you know
every time I walk in out I wash my
[__] hands you got to wash your hands
before you piss I do yeah I didn't know
that I didn't know that but that's the
biggest way that H HPV is spread you sh
you shake your hands with somebody and
then you going to touch your dick and
you wash your hands afterwards I never
thought about that yeah dude my doctor
told me that cuz I thought I had that
[__] yeah that's the first thing I do
when then the next morning when I get in
the car I hand I I I sanitize the
steering wheel because I'm out all night
shaking hands and [__] and as you're
shaking people's hands you can feel that
they fingered somebody they got that
dried juice on their finger and [__]
this is [__] disgusting and the first
thing you do before you touch your dick
or anything you got to wash your hands
with hot hot hot hot water like you got
go and then put cold water and then and
then soap it up again and get the
fingers you almost burn your hands off
then what as often as you have to go to
the bathroom in the plan no you got to
wash you got to wash your hands every
time well I don't I don't need crazy hot
water that's his thing yeah you got to
burn you got to burn that mother I use
some hot water yeah you got to burn that
[__] that's how they kill the
germs for sure that those germs that
they're coming over now this ain't no
[__] duck walk I think you're all
lying I think everyone here is
masturbated on an airplane and it's
bugging me I thought everyone's be like
oh yeah I get it yeah completely you
guys looked at me like I'm a [__]
[__] to take your dick out on a plane
is unheard of and just whack off now if
you're going to [__] somebody or get a
[__] in a I'm with you 150% no in the
bathroom though not just in your seat no
that's just that's even more disgusting
that is the most uncomfortable [__]
thing that's ever even smells like [__]
oh it smells like that there's cameras
they're watching you for sure they're
not watching you the bathro they're
watching you for sure telling you we got
too much money invested for them not to
be it's like Las Vegas they can't lose
those planes they want to make sure for
sure if they see somebody going in there
and strapping something they see it
trust me can you Google that can you fun
oh yeah yeah yeah going to tell you that
[__] because they're that
stupid I've never even heard this
conspiracy they're creepy [__] you have
listen it's not a conspiracy this is how
you have to
assume go and next time you go in that
[__] bathroom why is that mirror so
wide when you go to Las Vegas the mirror
is like this whenever you go in the
bathroom on a plane in the front by the
pilot that mirror is completely wide all
the way to the
end I think you have to assume every
inch of that plan on camera I assume all
that [__] going happen but we've had
we've had terrorist attacks we've had
terrorist attacks we've had the guy with
the [__] sneakers and the plan
afterwards there's no cameras on any of
those planes and now I bet there are I
would bet You' see them there's Not
Invisible cameras you have to assume
there's something going on in those PL
you have to assume there's something
going on at those airports there's too
much money invested in a flight business
for a plane to go down to the United
States right now it would just to throw
us yeah it would just kill us there's
too much I'm I'm I'm telling you right
now they pick me up jerking off on the
Black Box okay I'm telling you right now
that they've
got four miles from every airplane from
every airport is under [__] strict
surveillance four miles oh yeah I
believe bumper you can't do anything in
those four [__] blocks if they see
you doing something suspicious they will
call a black and white like an anonymous
tip but they have those four blocks that
TSA the NCA the FBI those four miles
around LAX are wi for sound don't think
that I every time I take my dick out and
piss when I get out cuz when you get to
LAX it's 40 minutes 30 minutes you had
coffee when I [__] first thing I do is I
open the door and take my dick out make
believe I'm looking through my luggage
I'm peeing Jack I'm peeing that coffee
is coming out of me that [__] almond
milk smoothie that's coming out of me
and I know that if I sit there for a
couple more minutes somebody's going to
show up a cop will mysteriously show up
they always
do yeah they always do because that's
under all they they got to watch those
parking garages I know what they tell
you that's against the law I know
against whose
law against whose [__] law you have
to assume yeah when you go to Las Vegas
I had a friend who got arrested doing a
bump in the bathroom
store they had them on tape they had
them on tape from above that's your
privacy you think they give a [__] in
the B yeah but I thought public
bathrooms they can't have cameras they
can't do nothing again you have to
[__] assume I'm going to Vegas
tomorrow yeah yeah so while you're there
and you jerk open the closet they got
somebody watching you there too they got
we got a freak on the 12th floor again
is there an MRA from LA to Vegas no or
no train it's only a six-h hour [__]
bus
ride just he just rent a car I don't
drive I I haven't had a license since I
was
18 yeah I don't even want to hear this
[__] story cuz I know this is a doozy
you got caught whacking off in the trunk
in the summer you had a Taco Bell you
know no it wasn't it was I I moved to
New York City you don't need a car in
the city so that was it I I had unpaid
tickets and it just got suspended and
that was that but now they got like uh
this chick was telling me last night
they have um like Airbnb for cars you go
to a city and you just rent somebody's
car for them for like a third of the
cost the cost to rent a car yeah yeah
the one's called like Lux I think I know
he's going to jump on that bandwagon no
cuz they have things where you can he's
going to call and make him your new
sponsor now that we put him through
sales training they have um they have
things now where you can get free
Airport parking and then they they rent
your car out when you're gone and then
you supposedly get paid too if they rent
your car
out people are selling their SS for a
buck now they don't give a [__] Jack
they don't give a [__] Lou Gomez anytime
you're in town I know you got to get to
The Comedy Store I say 20 already
cousins were 420 you know what I'm
saying there you go who you think you're
dealing with here Joey
bananas Joe you're the [__] you're
the man dude you're the man thank when
you're when you're in New York man
please come on Legion of skanks now you
guys do Saturdays right no we do
Tuesdays and Wednesdays that's the
problem I'm not New York Tuesdays and
[__] Wednesdays no no no let me let
me rephrase this if you come on a
Saturday just let me know we'll just do
a pre-tape we'll make it work man you
know I mean you're you're a guy who
we've get you know tons of request for I
mean you know it's [__] Joey Diaz
you're a legend you're a legend I come
on with Lee in September we [__] 100%
you guys open invite Le will be in
training by that time he'll be at600
milligrams to open like he's just
showing up with [__] eight stars like
listen like if we don't have eight Stars
we ain't get they're going to have to
make bigger Stars yeah I know we're
going we're thinking about the leis say
at deluxe edition th000 milligrams th000
milligrams with a picture
Israel who's better than [__] who the
Israel flag or what what huh look at the
Israeli flag or what we haven't de side
of yet there's a mountain top I
[Laughter]
like listen every [__] week I talk to
different people from Dean Del re to a
friend of mine in [__] uh in San
Diego her and her husband they go to
thousands of games and they're always
hustling prices I know a couple up in uh
in Pasadena my daughter's uh godmother
they got three kids they go to Laker
games they go to all that good stuff and
let me tell you something if you're
looking for tickets for
concerts games I mean anything like that
do me a favor what's the next big event
you want to go to all right Black
Sabbath maybe you wanted to go to Kobe's
thing maybe you want to go to the Dodges
against San Francisco whatever it is you
can bet that someone's going to pay less
for better seats how they you score big
you're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups and the last
minute convenience charges even printed
home fees you end up paying Courtside
prices for nose bleed seats score big is
here to change that do you know that 40%
of all Live Events go unsold and did you
know that there's a place to get these
seats at huge savings it's called score
big score big Works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold seats and unpublished prices all
right only score big you can name a
ticket price and be guaranteed to pay
below box office up to 60% off that's
right 60% off that's right 60% off bring
that beat back here's what you do one
you go to scorebig.com or download the
new score big app for your iPhone and
find the event and seats that you want
takes a few minutes boom boom boom two
make an offer on score Big's name a
ticket price feature all right three
getting an instant answer and save up to
60% on your ticket never any fees and
shipping is always free you can count on
unbeatable prices and great seats and
when you're in great seats you actually
enjoy the game or the show all the more
so do me a favor next time you go see
any game or show go to score big first
and see how much you can save for the
easiest way to save on tickets download
the new score big app right now right
now don't [__] around this is a [__]
this is unbelievable score big app for
your iPhone andent the promo code Joey
at checkout Joey Jo OE Y at checkout and
you'll save an extra $20 off your first
ticket purchase all right that's what
I'm doing for you tonight [__] no
iPhone no problem no speaky no Spanish
get $20 offline too at scorebig.com
that's scorebig.com promo code Joey Joe
wide that's scorebig.com promo Jo promo
code Joey your mother [__] got me
with the one more I love headspace I
love uh score big and I love H it thank
you for sponsoring the show I love Lou
Gomez he's a [__] Soldier ad de I
love Lisi and always I love the
beautiful Becky Ramos whatever the
[__]
name thank you brother I love you [__]
suckers I'm in Buffalo tomorrow night
Friday and Saturday where's my man where
you at this weekend all right I'm going
to be well this I got I'm doing one spot
in Vegas but go May 13th Legion of skank
presents where are you in Vegas uh I'm
doing a spot it's just a guest spot at
um the Planet Hollywood in the mall
there's a spot Edwin San Juan I don't
know okay I want I bump that for you but
[__] that H it bring that beat back
Legion of skanks I'm sorry Legion of
skanks present May 13th Louis J Gomez
Dave Smith with special guest Dan Soder
at the Hustler Club in Detroit um that's
going to be a [__] killer show um
obviously all my other dates New York
City dates everything on Gomez
comedy.com check out Legion of skanks
check out the countdown on Sirius XM
Rush 93 myself and Michael Bisping every
Thursday 600 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
H oh and the real ass podcast my [__]
my my illegitimate child podcast which
we [__] this that's a little more
like this we go [__] deep it's not
just craziness like Legion of skanks uh
that's gas digital network.com brand new
network we started every Friday at 12:00
noon there you go I'm in Buffalo
tomorrow night [__] tomorrow
night's tonight jazzed up started
Friday next week
Indianapolis and don't forget to what's
the name of full frontal Comedy full
frontal
podcast look at the shape of this
[__] J it don't [__] matter I love
you guys we're going to talk again
Monday night 8:00 pm we got a surprise
guest coming in thank you again for 420
whatever the [__] you're doing get
stoned to the gills I love you stay
black dude thanks man thank you my
brother cheers brother I really mean
that was [__] great really fun we
don't [__] around thank you
man oh [__] little Eros Smith for you
[__] suckers little Seasons of Wither
what what do you
[Music]
[Applause]
think
[Music]
Loose H
ladyy was
she
love for the
[Music]
devil heart to
me
SE of a
thousand drawn to
sin
SE
with
[Music]
oh
ooh is me I feel
[Music]
soing from
you
ooh is me feel so
s live all you in time I'm the lose your
mind live on borrow time take the wind
right out of your
[Music]
s fire daning my heat of how dogs the
Bay of the
Moon my ship leaves in the
midnight can't say have me back too
soon
ITW far far
away
he my C
out show me the way
[Applause]
sees the
Thousand drawn to her
in
seasons of
weather hold in
me
ooh me I feel so
bad
here live for
you ooh who is me I feel so
[Music]
s you in town I'm to lose your mind live
on borrow time take a win right out of
your
s
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]